Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu unserer kleine welt mein name ist.
Ich begrüße alle zur ausgabe vierundzwanzig und heute heißt es mal wieder corona und ich sag hallo zu pavel hallo pavel.
Eine woche ist wieder herum und wie es hier schon der ritus ist wollen wir mal ein wenig auf das zahlen und digital geschehen rund um diese korona krise blicken.
Und versuchen zu verstehen was uns denn alles so um die ohren geworfen wird und ein bisschen einzusammeln und unseren eigenen senf dazuzugeben.
Ich würde sagen wir fangen an mit dem feedbacks gab es nicht so viel kommentare zur letzten sendung aber so ein paar sachen die vielleicht nochmal wert sind aufgegriffen zu werden.
Gibt ja immer sehr unterschiedliche sichtweisen auf
alles eine sache die etwas aufstieß bei manchen war so unsere debatte um das mögliche ende dieser krise,
was denn damit gemeint sein könnte und das ist ja nun nicht bedeutet dass dann auf einmal alles vorbei ist und alles ist wieder so wie vorher ich hoffe das haben wir auch nicht so gesagt.
Nee ich meine wir hätten wir haben dazu gesagt nein wir haben dazu gesagt irgendwie das natürlich folgen bleiben werden dass es nicht also wie wie nach nein eleven ist ja mit ende ist einfach gemeint dass die.
Ausbreitung gestoppt oder unter kontrolle ist und die zahlen so niedrig sind dass man im
wesentlichen wieder all die dinge tun kann die man im moment noch nicht so tun kann oder die meisten davon jedenfalls so kneipen aufsuchen
auf jeden fall und ja reisen.
Und alles mit einer zwar nicht ganz ohne gefahr aber zumindest mit einer mit einem vertretbaren risiko.
Dann ist ende.
Zumindest dass man sagen kann jetzt sind wir in eine neue phase eingetreten die nicht die aktuelle phase ist.
Dann gibt es natürlich auch immer wieder kommentare rund um die voraussagen kraft unserer betrachtung.
Und dazu kann ich immer nur sagen ich meine alle arten von fitz also wenn man halt versucht kurven
funktion anzupassen an die bisherigen daten können natürlich nur begrenzt in die zukunft gucken also wissen jetzt nicht wenn sich irgendein
parameter ändert oder wenn er sich anders ändert als das.
Modell es voraussicht aber was ich halt mache ist ich gucke mir dann sagen die letzten vierzehn tage beispielsweise an oder die letzte woche.
Wie sich die vorhersagen dann verändern und ob es da tendenzen gibt das heißt was die fits machen können sind quasi.
Leitlinien zu geben und dann kann man sehen so okay so hätte es zu dem zeitpunkt
eigentlich verlaufen können oder sollen oder müssen aber jetzt läuft's halt schlechter oder besser oder es wurde mal besser und jetzt wird's wieder schlechter solche aussagen kann man damit
eben wunderbar machen aber natürlich wenn sich irgendwas ändert.
So an der ausbreitung dann können die fetzt das halt auch nicht wissen dann ist das halt in den bisherigen daten schlichtweg einfach nicht enthalten und was in den bisherigen daten nicht enthalten ist kann man halt auch an signal nicht.
Generieren.
Was ich selten gehört habe wo ich mir dachte ob denn das nicht eigentlich doch ein ganz guter vergleich es ist so der wetterbericht.
Ja da gab es immer wieder mal vergleiche aber beim wetterbericht sieht's halt.
Doch noch ein bisschen anders aus sonst sagen da hat man also erstens.
So weiß man über das wetter teilweise deutlich mehr auf der anderen seite ist es dann wiederum deutlich komplexer als jetzt so eine so eine ausbreitung also ich glaube der vergleich hinkt ein bisschen so.
Ja der der hängt auf jeden fall aber auch hier geht es ja darum oder ging es vor allem und geht es natürlich auch immer noch modelle zu bauen und überhaupt erstmal
erkenntnisse darüber zu lernen welche parameter.
Spiel überhaupt eine rolle und in welchem maße spielen die eine rolle und das ist ja eine hohe kunst und eine krasse wissenschaft die
jetzt jahrzehnte wenn ich sogar jahrhunderte gebraucht hat um mit einem.
Nicht unbeträchtlichen aufwand überhaupt erstmal daten zu sammeln um in so 'ne situation zu kommen dass man mal gerade mal zwei wochen vorher sagen kann.
Was mittlerweile irgendwie gelingt zu räumen und meine wir werden jetzt hier schon ganz froh wenn man zwei wochen vorher sagen können.
Aber das ist eigentlich der einzige vergleich den ich machen wollte das ist einfach eine komplexe materie ist und die dinge sich halt eben auch ändern können und es auch tun und.
Wir versuchen halt hier einfach nur zu verstehen und wir versuchen jetzt nicht nur zu verstehen was eigentlich gerade passiert
indem wir also den august und der tagesschau zuhören und dann das
einfach so zur kenntnis zu nehmen war auch noch
ein bisschen genauer zu verstehen was eigentlich passiert und was hier eine rolle haben kann und denke bei den allermeisten fällen haben wir bisher eigentlich auch im wesentlichen immer festgestellt so ja okay so läuft es auch und
das sind hier die faktoren an denen gerade gedreht wird um das ganze verstehen zu können.
Dann blicken wir doch mal auf die letzte woche es gab ja ein paar neuigkeiten unter anderem
ist ja diese gange studie jetzt endlich veröffentlicht worden.
Ja das ist auf jeden fall noch mal wieder einen wald.
Hilfreicher datenpunkte weil diese woche stand bei mir zumindest so ein bisschen auch im
zeichen der dunkelziffern weil
so langsam kommen wir nämlich in einer phase wo immer mehr und mehr studien kommen die es ermöglichen immer bessere abschätzung der dunkelziffer vornehmen,
zu können und das ist halt ganz ganz wichtig natürlich die unterscheidet sich halt.
Dürfte sie in verschiedenen ländern doch deutlich unterscheiden das kann man,
auch sagen dass das wusste man schon vorher einfach aufgrund des verhältnisses von gezählten also von infektionen und todesfällen da,
sie sind zwischen verschiedenen ländern so weit auseinander gelaufen dass man ganz klar sagen konnte okay das kann nicht
real sein das sind die fakten beziehungsweise sind halt dunkelziffern und letztlich weiß man dass die zahl der toten halt
die verlässliche ist aber die kommt eben auch später und in.
Insofern ja super interessante zahlen und aus der gange studie die ja jetzt einen sogenannten also ein verhältnis von denen die sich infizieren.
Sterben null komma drei sechs prozent
trosten sagt in seinem letzten podcast so wie er das auf ein bier deckel gerechnet hat so kommt er eher auf null komma vier fünf
prozent so aufgrund anderer gewichtungen was bestimmte tests aussagen oder nicht aber das liegt jetzt lang schon mal.
Relativ nah beieinander und new york gab es jetzt auch eine studie die rum ging auch eine immunität studium angeguckt hat wie viele leute hatten das virus denn schon.
Da kann man in die gegend null komma acht prozent chinesische studien lagen auch bei null komma acht prozent wobei man da dann noch,
sagen muss es sieht so aus also es ist jetzt auch im verlauf der pandemien scheint es auch keine konstante
zu sein sondern immer auch eine momentaufnahme aus verschiedenen gründen einmal weil man nie weiß wie viele leute eigentlich noch sterben so meistens ist es so ein problem bei den studien weil
oft sind die zu ende und dann.
Wenn man die jetzt anguckt monat später weiß man aber das noch zwei drei fünf leute mehr gestorben sind wenn man überhaupt nur zehn tote hatte und fünf sterben noch später dann ist wirkt sich das natürlich auch
ganz schön krass auf das ergebnis aus es kann aber auch real
sein dass die sich über die zeit verändert so oder zumindest in in bestimmten bereichen weiß man jetzt auch noch nicht aber tendenziell ist es ja
eben auch so gut auf wenn angeblich dieses virus sehr mutationen ist mutiert es halt doch und
generell sind mutationen eigentlich nicht gut für einen virus also normalerweise wird es nicht besser beim notieren so nur in wirklich ausnahmefällen und dann gibt's natürlich auch noch sowas wie einen evolutionsbedingt.
Wenn wir jetzt leute in quarantäne schicken die symptome haben dann,
kann sich einen virus was halt viel symptome macht nicht so gut ausbreiten wie eins was irgendwie vielleicht mutiert ist und ein bisschen unterwegs ist also ein bisschen einfach weniger,
starke symptome macht oder später symptome oder wie auch immer das heißt wenn sich das virus verändert,
aus meiner sicht dann eher dahin dass auch tendenziell weniger leute sterben
im moment haben wir aber erstmal die ersten datenpunkte so ein bisschen vorbei also in der chinesischen studie und da bin ich mir noch nicht sicher ob das auch einen erhebung artefakt war weil sie hinten abgeschnitten haben aber da war es so je später jemand
im laufe der erkrankt ist umso besser waren seine überlebenschancen soviel vielleicht zudem
thema weil der verrät uns halt unglaublich viel über die dunkelziffer weil beispielsweise im fall von deutschland.
Wenn man jetzt den csd f also die fall sterberate.
Einfach nimmt von jetzt was gleich wo wir wo wir liegen bei vier komma irgendwas und teilt die dann einfach durch die null komma vier fünf dann.
Kommt man halt auf einen faktor von zehn.
Beispielsweise relativ einfach eine division und schon weiß man halt in etwa wie hoch die dunkelziffer.
Ist wenn man diesen kennt jedenfalls bei der infizierten und deswegen ist das halt so spannend.
Also fälle nochmal gleich klarzumachen leute die eben symptome der krankheit zeigen damit als fall gelten und infizierte halt leute
ja von dem mann weiß oder annimmt dass dass sie diesen virus in sich tragen auch wenn sie vielleicht keine symptome haben und das ist ja jetzt quasi die große frage also wenn jetzt die ganze studie sagt ja okay null komma
drei sechs prozent der leute die infiziert sind sterben.
Dann kann man sich ja dann wiederum in der gesamtbevölkerung einfach mal anschauen ja okay wie viel sind denn jetzt bei uns gestorben und wenn man das einfach in die andere richtung rechnet müsste man ja dann.
Quasi auf eine infizierten zahl kommen.
Natürlich nicht der zahl entspricht die wir derzeit herum reichen weil das sind ja eben nur die die man entdeckt hat und die dunkelziffer ist jetzt eben die frage wie groß ist denn jetzt dieser faktor und.
Ja
Ja also trotzdem sagt dorsten sagt sechs so also vier bis acht sagt er die zahlen
er deuten eher so auf zehn hin also man sichergehen will gar für deutschland mit zehn rechnen
ja
Was heißt sichergehen will.
Naja.
Eine zu hoch angenommene dunkelziffer ist ja viel leitend weil man dann annimmt hätten ja mehr und im hinblick auf die gesamte mobilität der gesellschaft kann man sich dann natürlich auch schnell vertun.
Aussagen ja es ist faktor hundert und so jetzt haben schon fast alle so ist ja auch nicht.
Nee das nicht aber sagen jetzt faktor zehn wenn man so betrachtung und risiko- einfach machen.
Möchte sowie riskant ist das kommen wir vielleicht hinterher auch noch zu wenn wir genauer in die deutschen zahlen nochmal reingehen aber ich fand,
in den letzten trosten podcast achtunddreißig ja gab es noch weitere interessante dinge einmal hinweis zur hintergrundbild immunität.
So die man immer auch noch nicht genau kennt aber die könnte jetzt für den fall.
Das jetzt die infektion plötzlich verschwindet ohne dass wir irgendwie was tun oder oder früher verschwindet trotz dass wir jetzt maßnahmen zurückfahren dann könnte ein grund dafür laut trosten
die hintergrund immunität sein die daherkommt dass leute die durch andere korona viren sich früher angesteckt haben möglicherweise auch eine immunität oder eine teil
gegenüber des dem neuen corona virus haben und das sagen wir die dazurechnen müssten und wenn das viele sind dann.
Hätten wir hier eben früher herden immunität erreicht durch diese hintergrund aber trotzdem geht davon aus dass es nicht der fall ist aber für den fall.
Das virus plötzlich verschwindet könnte das sagen eine mögliche erklärung sein.
Andere erklärung ist natürlich saisonalität wobei die nicht sehr groß zu sein scheint dritte erklärung hatten wir gerade das virus vielleicht einfach auch schwächer wird oder sich eben sagen motivation,
dahingehend auswirken dass wir halt auch infektionen weniger mitbekommen.
Und es werden so möglichkeiten wenn wir feststellen dass es schneller zurück geht ja dann fand ich auch noch interessant.
So nochmal ein hinweis weil es immer die die debatte so ja lassen wir es irgendwie jetzt laufen und lassen wir die bevölkerung jetzt irgendwo durch infizieren und.
Da kann man nur sagen so es gilt unbedingt nach wie vor zu vermeiden selbst wenn wirkt die kapazität haben.
Für intensivbehandlung so eine jemanden zu beatmen so das zieht halt schwerwiegende gesundheitsschäden nach sich
so speziell auch bei älteren leuten depressionen frühere demenz und und und insofern denke ich
es ist das nach wie vor auch aus dem grund selbst wenn die leute überleben gibt's viele viele gute gründe einfach dass sich möglichst.
Niemand mehr ansteckt damit bis einen impfstoff da ist oder möglichst wenig ansteckendes impfstoff da ist oder das auf andere art und weise zum stehen kommt.
Oder man zumindest medikamente hat irgendwelche maßnahmen aber es halt einfach gibt sehr viele berichte die sagen ja könnte sein dass es noch organspenden gibt.
Berichte die sagen es könnte auch sein dass die schlaganfall wahrscheinlichkeit steigt auch bei jugendlichen etcetera also es gibt einfach da so viele faktoren die man noch überhaupt gar nicht sehen kann mal ganz abgesehen davon dass wir wissen dass eben.
Allein diese standard anführungsstrichen standard neunzehn krankheit an sich halt schon gefährlich genug ist.
Ja dann was ja gerade auch immer wieder aufkommt ist das thema schule wo vielleicht ganz ganz kurz auch noch drauf ein.
Gehen sollten so da wurde auch im trosten podcast halt diese französische schulstufe diskutiert und im prinzip
wurde die schule einmal so zu
vierzig bis sechzig prozent durch infiziert so schüler achtunddreißig prozent lehrer dreiundvierzig interessant sonstiges personal also haus weiß der putz kräfte oder wie auch immer zu sechzig prozent sogar
und nach hause getragen haben sie es auch aber nur so zehn prozent der geschwister und zwölf prozent der eltern haben sich durch ihre kinder.
Infiziert auch vielleicht interessante zahlen klar ist natürlich auch wieder anzuzweifeln aber im großen und ganzen ist es auf jeden fall ein guter anhaltspunkt dass man sagen kann okay.
Wenn man es in so einer schule einfach schulbetrieb macht.
Wie normal dann infiziert sich die schule in null komma nix einmal komplett durch.
Muss man kurz kurze anmerkung also das war eine schule die dann nicht dicht gemacht wurde wegen der krankheiten sondern,
da haben dann die normalen schulferien gegriffen und dann war die schule dicht und danach wurde erst klar oh hier gab's aber viele ausbrüche und das hat man sich dann nochmal genauer angeschaut aber dann ist natürlich wieder die frage wen testest du denn eigentlich.
Wobei es speziell in dem fall gründe gibt einmal wurden halt nur freiwillige getestet da gibt's normalerweise den effekt dass sich eher leute melden die halt getestet werden wollen die als symptome hatten so das ist halt
sagen in die richtung dass man dann höhere zahlen kriegt aber in dem fall war es halt so dass sie leute auch so getestet wurden.
Wegen dem ausbruch unabhängig von der studie das heißt die meisten wussten halt schon ihr ergebnis das heißt,
deswegen kann's halt sein dass viele gesagt haben was interessiert mich die studie ich habe mein ergebnis
ich brauche mich nicht nochmal testen zu lassen für diese studie ich wollte ja schon getestet so und vielleicht kompensiert sich das aber wie auch immer ich denke mal die größenordnung.
Lässt sich da nicht wegdiskutieren aber wie gesagt im moment wird natürlich versucht.
Schulen eben nicht normal laufen zu lassen sondern irgendwie schulunterricht
social distance sing und anderen schutzmaßnahmen zu verbinden und ich denke mal das wird wahrscheinlich irgendein effekt haben
aber und.
Um es kurz vorwegzunehmen daher ist es so dass etwa.
Im moment jeder tausendsiebenhundert im schnitt gerade infektiös es so.
Offiziell vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr aber so ja jeder.
So das bedeutet dass wenn man so größere schulen hat oder mittelgroße so mit tausend schülern wenn man so eine schule aufmacht,
in jeder zweiten schule einfach sitzt halt ein infiziertes mit im unterricht.
Im schnitt.
Im schnitt so und,
wir haben halt den deutschland sechszehntausendvierhundertzweiundsiebzig und ungefähr sechzehntausend weiterführende schulen so das heißt die hälfte davon von
so sitzt dann ein infizierten und das ist natürlich das problem du machst die schule auf.
Ich meine erstens kommen dann eventuell noch andere dazu die sich anders wo dann infizieren aber der eine ist schon mal da und wenn in dem moment wo der jetzt getestet wird oder symptome kriegt.
Muss man eigentlich die schule wieder zumachen weil dann hast du halt
die krankheit an der schule so und das ist jetzt auch das ist auch mehrfach vorgekommen mit schulen die geöffnet haben und das problem nur bei dem test regime im moment.
Wo ist das vorgekommen.
Bin ich glaub in nordrhein-westfalen oder so ich hab's jetzt.
Wann wurde schulen geöffnet.
Naja es gab irgendwo schulhöfen und dann musste irgendwie drei tage später wieder zugemacht werden weil man infektionen hatte.
Hab ich raussuchen nicht meldung und das ist so ein bisschen das das.
Problem beziehungsweise weil sich das ja auch eventuell unter unter schülern auch stelle noch also weniger symptomatisch ausbreitet und nicht so viel getestet.
Wird dort kann's halt sein dass du plötzlich nach zwei drei wochen feststellst erst wenn plötzlich fälle kommen so oder so.
Mehr fälle mit symptomen kommen und getestet wird dass plötzlich dann schon in der zeit mein webinar.
Einer ist so bei der generationstag von von vier tagen und eventuell oder auch noch so ein super sprinter dann kannst du in drei wochen schon zehn zwanzig prozent der schüler infiziert,
haben mehr bevor du es überhaupt gemerkt hast und dann hast du.
Wieder nennen das ist dann ein echter ausbruch und bei sechzehntausend schulen also ich muss sagen die zahlen sehen da jetzt für für schulaufführung aus meiner sicht gar nicht gut
aus und letztlich hängt es alles davon wie wirksam die schutzmaßnahmen sind an den an den schulen und wie sehr sich die schüler daran halten oder nicht und ja.
Da habe ich schon ein paar schlimme geschichten gelesen auf twitter so dass es einfach extrem schwierig durchzusetzen ist dass es nicht ausreichend ernst genommen wird und.
Ja alle alle die versuchen da stärkere maßnahmen durchzusetzen einfach schwierigkeiten haben ganz davon abgesehen dass natürlich die ganzen auflagen die jetzt ohnehin noch versucht werden durchzuziehen
einfach dazu führen dass auch dieser unterricht selber einfach auch noch mal extrem stressig ist.
Alle soll nochmal hände waschen bevor sie von der pause reinkommen ja okay dann hast du da zwei waschbecken so schüler.
So dauert dann halt einfach auch mal zehn minuten und dementsprechend geht's später los.
Und ich weiß auch gut
ich weiß nicht ob sich das mittlerweile allzu sehr geändert hat und es gibt sicherlich auch solche und solche schulen aber so gut war es ja auch auf einer ganz speziellen schule aber so bei mir waren die lehrer waren einfach der feind
so irgendwann so das war halt schon ja,
also wenn die irgendeine schwäche dargeboten haben wenn die irgendwie versucht nett zu sein so dass namenlos ausgenutzt.
So als als schüler und also,
womit wir durchkommen konnten so haben wir halt probiert durchzukommen so also das war schon und bis hin zu wirklich wir haben lehrer gerade referendare oder so echt fertig gemacht wir waren echt arschlöcher als schüler muss ich sagen.
Seid ihr sicherlich nicht alleine.
Und.
Jetzt in der situation ja das ist alles nicht schön und rein nur den zahlen nach wie gesagt wenn man selbst wenn man nach den nach den offiziellen infektionsbad bezahlen.
Geht die sich weitgehend jetzt mit meinem auch decken ist es so dass gerade in jeder zweiten schule die du aufmachst so einen infizierten drin hast und das geht eigentlich nicht das kannst du eigentlich nicht machen.
Wobei das ist ja jetzt auch die zahl wiederum für deutschland und es gibt ja nun auch bundesländer in denen sie es wirklich sehr viel besser aus also ich glaube mecklenburg-vorpommern ist,
glaube ich der vorreiter ohnehin ein land was hat einerseits schön weit weg von ist und.
Vielleicht auch aus der situation her nicht so viele glauber am start hatte wie andere länder dazu kommt noch dass es eben auch relativ dünn besiedelt ist sich das eben du hast nicht.
Kein karneval.
Karneval.
Nicht so viele nicht so viele bierfest wie in bayern und.
Genau man kann es ja auch an den zahlen einfach sehen mecklenburg-vorpommern ist auf jeden fall ganz weit vorne und wäre insofern natürlich auch am ehesten dafür prädestiniert mit den schulen voranzuschreiten.
Um dann zu sehen wie es sich auswirkt.
Aber aus meiner sicht braucht es irgendwie noch mindestens faktor zehn und selbst dann ist es echt
kritisch eigentlich eigentlich hätte man dieses halbjahr einfach in die tonne kloppen sollen und dann irgendwie besten auch noch.
Alle sommer schulferien mit bayern synchronisieren so die haben nämlich immer zuletzt wusstest du das.
Ja ja ja die haben da so eine so eine sondern sonst sonderrecht.
Ja genau.
So alle werden auf spät geschoben alle schulferien und alle machen dann halt ausnahmsweise mal ja erst irgendwann im oktober wieder auf und.
September.
Heißt aber dann auch drei monate ferien.
Und entsprechend gestresste eltern so die natürlich in dem moment da die ja auch arbeiten müssen
das betreuungsprogramme natürlich nochmal doppelt und dreifach habe ich meine man weiß ja jetzt schon noch nicht mal was man in sommerferien machen soll wenn sich überhaupt gar keine urlaubssituationen anbieten ja wenn man die kinder noch nicht mal irgendwo auf dem pferdehof schicken kann ja.
Ja wobei wie gesagt da haben wir uns ja beim letzten neu ich mich zumindest aus dem fenster gelehnt dass ja.
Wenn wir wenn wir jetzt nicht zu früh aufmachen so dann stehen die chancen für den sommerurlaub eigentlich ganz gut auch für den sommerurlaub im ausland aus meiner sicht zumindest im.
September vielleicht sogar schon im august in manchen ländern schon im juli.
Ja aber ich glaube einfach dass bezüglich klassischer urlaubs.
Ja also insbesondere durch italien und spanien große vorbehalte
existieren dürfen egal wie gut sich das da jetzt entwickelt und so mega gut ist die situation dort ja auch derzeit noch nicht oder das halt auch sowas wie mallorca ja wo sich
alle auf appelle hocken das wird halt einfach ja ein entsprechenden druck in deutsch gebiete.
Für einen druck in deutsche urlaubsgebiete sorgen man sich halt auch fragt so sind die da überhaupt zu einer lage das aufzunehmen oder entsteht da nicht wieder die nächste enge also es ist schwierig.
Sag ich's nicht nichts unmöglich aber es ist auf jeden fall schwierig und von daher kann ich auch verstehen dass hier ein entsprechender politischer druck auch entsteht weil es natürlich einfach viele eltern gibt die einfach sagen so ja ihr müsst die schulen wieder aufmachen.
Weil sie ist halt das risiko anders einschätzen als wir es jetzt vielleicht in diesem moment getan haben.
Wie gesagt die frage ist sagen wie viel ausbrüche in schulen können wir uns leisten und verkraften so das muss man einfach sehen und im moment,
aus meiner sicht ist das ist das eine.
Eine riesige bombe die da droht zu platzen und eigentlich ja gut wir werden sehen wir werden sehen.
Ich hoffe ich behalte,
unrecht und die maßnahmen schüler sind alle vernünftig und uns kommen hoffentlich sagt diese anderen effekte die
die ausbreitung abschwächen noch zur hilfe dann wäre alles gut aber das ist halt schon war bank spiel gerade.
Hast du denn da von anderen kreativen lösungen gehört ich meine man könnte ja auch sagen ich formuliere jetzt mal ein wenig es gibt
sozusagen gar nicht die sommerferien sondern bestimmte klassen haben jetzt urlaub
bestimmte klassen zeuge haben jetzt schule und die schule verteilt sich sozusagen gleichmäßig über die nächsten monate so dass man eben auch sehr viel kleinere
gruppen hat den schulen sollen ja auch mehr platz bieten et cetera ist natürlich schwierig dann die lehrer.
Und wenn du dann geschwister hast in einem auch.
Oh ja okay.
Es ist ja eine.
Ja und mit den lehrern und stundenpläne und sowas glaube ich alles nicht so ohne weiteres auf die reihe das kannst du.
Oder einfach konsequent digital walter schulen so.
Das.
Das ist das ich meine klar es ist natürlich auch ein sozialraum und auch ja die kids wollen natürlich irgendwie auch ihre freunde sehen und treffen und tun sie halt vielleicht sowieso.
Unter noch unkontrollierten türen bedingungen aber im moment.
Ja aus meiner sicht ist das von von allen maßnahmen.
Von allen lockerungen sehe ich halt die die schulaufführung zumindest logisch ist das wahrscheinlich die gefährlichste aktion.
Achso und dann natürlich was gar nicht ob wir das beim letzten mal schon angesprochen hatte diese französische studie über kurvig bei rauchern so so als raucher fand ich das natürlich.
Halt super interessant also es gibt eine studie und die wurde auch in dem droste podcast angesprochen.
Die besagt dass brauche seltener sich infizieren was man weiß umgekehrt wenn sie sich infizieren verläuft die krankheit schwerer bei rauchern.
Aber laut dieser französischen studie und trosten.
Glaubt halt nicht dran und findet das so unglaublich dass er sich sogar geweigert hat die zahlen zu nennen in seinem podcast.
Hallo.
Wird vorsichtig.
Das war irgendwie sowas wie das raucher glaube ich eine viermal ich will wissen jetzt nicht beschwören aber es war so,
viermal weniger geringere chance haben sich zu infizieren als nichtraucher laut,
dieser studie und er meint gut die ist doch nicht review und unglaubliche behauptungen verlangen eigentlich auch unglaubliche beweise
so
Und ja also er er zweifelt an den zahlen aber franzosen sind ja auch immer spezialisten für solche dinge höre nicht auf diese studie kennst damals
die auch besagte dass rotwein irgendwie vor herzinfarkt schützt wo sie festgestellt hat dass näher.
Vor krebs und was nicht alles.
Die ganzen sie hatten eine studie bei obdachlosen und festgestellt also bei obdachlosen alkoholikern die sich hat halt vor allem rotwein trinken und dann festgestellt dass die halt irgendwie alle.
Viel bessere wie auch immer so und insofern an diesem studio wusste ich halt denken als ich das kann ich das so eine studie kann auch nur aus frankreich wieder.
Ja da sind wir wieder mit korrelation und kausalität von und so.
Nee also bin gespannt ich finde ich finde es natürlich als raucher erfreulich wenn dem so wäre keine ahnung aber ja.
Das lassen wir mal außen vor.
Genau ja.
Zahlen dann mein deutschland kann man sagen ja liegen
im rahmen der entwicklung also der sieben tages ist auch
jetzt niedriger denn denn je zuvor auch in meinen berechnungen in anderen berechnungen sagen tagesaktuell lang auf null komma fünf runtergehüpft sogar
naja aber das sind halt auch wie.
Tagesaktuell mit diesem.
Mit diesen wöchentlichen schwankungen ja ja aber es wurde halt von anderen vermeldet deswegen so ja es wurde glaube ich hier von
helmholz genau helmholz haben wir glaube ich irgendwas von null komma fünf
gesagt aber so ja ist trotzdem also bisher noch in den zahlen sitzt im im wochenschau den ich halt nur mache um die wochentags schwankungen möglichst rauszukriegen sind wir halt auch irgendwo null komma sieben
also die niedrigste niedrigste wochenschau den ich je hatte bisher also es gibt
deswegen noch keine anzeichen dass es irgendwie also für einen großartigen anstieg.
Bewegt sich halt alles im rahmen und jetzt lohnt sich 's halt auch vor allem immer auf die neuinfektionen gerade.
Zu gucken also offiziell haben wir jetzt so neunhundert pro tag durchschnittlich und in echtzeit also sagen wenn wir die zehn tage meldet verzögerung ungefähr.
Versuchen rauszurechnen.
Dürften es eher so dreihundertfünfzig maximal vierhundert am tag sein und wenn wir dann jetzt sechsmal dunkelziffer drauf rechnen zweitausend bis zweieinhalbtausend
sagen die sich tatsächlich im moment jeden tag neu
infizieren inklusive derer die wir nicht sehen können die auch nicht in irgendwelchen die keine symptome haben und nicht getestet werden und nicht in tests auftauchen.
Was meinst du mit in echtzeit.
In echtzeit ich meine die zahlen die wir jetzt sehen die die die heute die jeden tag berichtet wurden die liegen ja.
Zehn tage zurück die tatsächlich die infektionen so beziehungsweise also.
Und das heißt das geschehen heute kriegen wir erst in zehn tagen
berichtet so und wenn man aber sagen dann die vorhersage macht wie es denn in zehn tagen ist sagt man eigentlich
vorher wie es heute ist und die vorhersage für ihn zehn tagen also heute sind halt eben dann dreihundertfünfzig
neuinfektionen am.
Okay also wenn heute neunhundert gemeldet werden dann könnte das heißen dass also in zehn tagen für heute dreihundertfünfzig gemeldet werden.
Aber da wäre diese dunkelziffer von mindestens sechsfach haben die müssen wir dann wieder drauf multiplizieren noch und dann kommen wir sagen auf zweitausendeinhundert heute.
So bei faktor sechs oder eben dreitausendfünfhundert wenn man jetzt mit faktor zehn rechnen will aber ich nehme.
Jetzt einfach mal den faktor sechs weil das ist was torsten gesagt hat wobei ich ja also ja faktor zehn wie gesagt kann kann auch sehr gut sein also eigentlich sollten die studien auf faktor zehn hin.
Zwei bis dreitausend sage ich mal.
Zwei bis dreitausend genau so und wenn man dann jetzt noch mal ausrechnet wie viel davon gerade,
ansteckend
sind weil das sind ja nicht nur die die gestern erkrankt sind sondern dass du mir jetzt sich natürlich über mehrere tage auf und das ist jetzt auch
meine rechnung die geht jetzt
dann von sankt dreizehneinhalb dreizehntausendsiebenhundertfünf ansteckende sagen vor zehn tagen auf basis der meldet zahlen in echtzeit,
ungefähr sechstausend heute ansteckend und dann wiederum mit dunkelziffer multipliziert werden sechsunddreißigtausend
ansteckende also zwischen vierundzwanzig und achtundvierzigtausend wenn man jetzt faktor acht nimmt ja,
irgendwo in der in der gegend bewegt sich das und so kommen wir dann nämlich wenn wir die achtundvierzigtausend halt runterrechnen dann kommen wir halt
auf diesen faktor eins zu dass jeder tausendsiebenhundert ungefähr gerade ansteckend ist.
Oder anders ausgedrückt man stellt sich einfach vor mit einem ein ganzes bundesligastart voll größeres bundesligastart voll mit
so die jetzt gleichmäßig über deutschland herab regnen so und dann kann man sich ausrechnen oder auch nicht ob man da gerade in der nähe steht ne.
Okay oder wenn wir jetzt bundesliga spiele veranstalten würden so wie viel geben bei union rein.
Bei union sind es nur zweiundzwanzigtausend.
Okay das heißt wir hätten da maximal so zehn bis fünfzehn infizierte dabei wenn wir jetzt ein spiel machen würden wären so zehn ansteckende sorry ansteckende.
Genau ansteckendes interessant ne also die zahl ist deshalb so groß weil auch leute die gestern gemeldet
wurden sind immer noch ansteckend nur weil sie nicht neu sind sind sie ja nicht aus der welt und deswegen laufen die rum und sind einfach nochmal fünf sechs tage lang ansteckend.
Somit ich glaube ich habe mit sieben tagen gerechnet das ist halt auch noch deutlich konservativer als die garant sie können auch noch bis tag zwanzig ansteckend sein aber irgendwie schnitt sind glaube ich sieben tage.
Und die sind aber auf jeden fall auch nicht alle gleich ansteckend nicht weil gerade die asymmetrischen also die die kein krankheitsbild zeigen
klar die können auch schreien jubeln singen und den moment auch eine gefahr die fangen zumindest nicht an zu husten.
Also union spielt werden wahrscheinlich zehn bis fünfzehn ansteckende dabei so also es macht dann schon bisschen klar die problematik so bei den zahlen die wir die wir im moment haben.
Vor allem bei union wo immer sehr eng gestanden und sehr laut gesungen wird.
Ja
Also das wäre glaube ich ein echter echtes desaster und ich meine wenn wir uns wenn wir gerade mal jetzt schon beim fußball sind.
Ich weiß nicht ob du das bundesliga-team ergebnis mitbekommen hast ob du das verfolgt hast ja.
Also das sind ja zehn von tausendsiebenhundert vierundzwanzig personen in der bundesliga positiv getestet worden so das heißt spieler trainer und irgendwie sonstiges betreuungspersonen.
Ja das wären halt sagen vierhundertsiebzigtausend
auf die gesamtbevölkerung gerechnet also diese diese rate so normal immer mehr er gerade gesagt ok ansteckend werden jetzt eigentlich bei tausend siebenhundertvierundzwanzig leuten was so ziemlich genau die zahl ist
dies sagen auf die ein eigentlich ein infektiöse gerade so kommen.
Müsste wobei natürlich wieder tests nicht
positiver test nicht heißen muss ansteckend weil der ist halt noch länger der test ist halt noch länger positiv wenn aber eigentlich die leute nicht mehr wirklich
jetzt ansteckend viren ausscheiden insofern kann man sagen ja gut.
Vielleicht zwei könnte vielleicht zwei oder dreimal so viel sein aber.
Faktor ziehen ist schon würde man eher sagen ist eher so eine art clustere könnte man sagen das ist sicherlich eine deutlich höhere rate als in der in der gesamten,
bevölkerung und das verheißt natürlich auch nichts gutes weil
es hat mir auch auch schon von ein paar podcasts dass er das problem ist warum man halt aufgehört hat ist dass in dem moment wo du in der mannschaft jetzt
infizierten hass musste die ganze mannschaft halt aus dem rennen nehmen so wie jetzt.
Bei diesen tests gutes verteilte sich jetzt weil ich weiß nie auf drei oder vier mannschaften oder so die werden halt jetzt dann schon mal raus plötzlich gerade.
Also ich glaube garantiert wurden dann nur kleinere gruppen man weiß ja jetzt nicht so ganz genau wer da jetzt mit welcher risikobewertung
getestet wurde weil
an der stelle greift ja dann auch gleich wieder dieses contact tracing die trainieren ja derzeit noch separat in kleineren gruppen et cetera also es heißt nicht dass sofort die ganze.
Mannschaft in quarantäne geht aber es droht natürlich insbesondere wenn sie sich jetzt alle wieder noch näher kommen dass das dann irgendwann passiert ne.
Also im moment nicht aber in dem moment wo du den spielbetrieb wieder aufnimmst kennst du ja nicht irgendwie also kannst ja nicht
social distance nur noch fernpost sind erlaubt vielleicht temporär die fußball regeln ändern dass sich die sagen nicht dass man sich die nicht näher als ja.
Regel genau die abstandsregelung wird halt auch auf dem fußballfeld eingeführt und sagen und wenn du jemanden näher kommst als zwei meter ist das ein foul.
Oh mann da kann man ja die gelben karten gleich in der kabine lassen.
Ja
Gut aber man muss natürlich auch sagen sie testen natürlich da auch extrem viel also ich das richtig sehe soll so im schnitt alle zweimal die woche getestet oder nicht im schnitt
alles alle sollen zwei mal die woche getestet werden insbesondere immer vor den spielen.
Das schafft ja dahingehend eine gewisse sicherheit man weiß davon ausgeht dass der test.
Auch das richtige anzeigt wobei bei den pc test kann man sich wohl ziemlich sicher sein dann ist halt relativ klar selbst wenn die person sich unmittelbar nach proben entnahme.
Infizieren würde wäre sie zum spieltag nicht ansteckend weil das einfach dauert weil es einfach.
Mindestens zwei tage dauert bis eben wirklich eine ansteckungsgefahr zeit vorliegt und von daher haben
sie hier schon ganz gute filter ist haben sie halt angefangen mit der testerin gibt es so eine ganze serie von tests wo halt jetzt mal konsequent durchgefüttert wird mit wie sieht's denn aus
da werden halt jetzt noch ein paar leute rausgezogen und dann muss man halt schauen wie es dann zum spieltags beginn der jetzt glaube ich so für mitte mai gemunkelt wird gab es gerade die entscheidung
bevor wir hier angefangen haben mit der sendung dass eben bundesliga spielen darf aber ich habe jetzt noch kein konkretes datum gesehen
glaube ich auch noch kein ganz konkretes.
Aber ohne publikum.
Das sowieso ja klar ich meine das steht vollkommen außer frage es dürfen sich glaube ich so maximal dreihundert leute im stadion aufhalten in verschiedenen zonen und so weiter gibt's ganz detaillierte pläne.
Sehr exklusiv dann so ein spiel zu sehen.
Dass es keine freude für alle beteiligten aber ich denke das ist auch vertretbar aber ganze bundesliga debatte ist ja nochmal ein ganz anderer teil den müssen wir jetzt hier nicht abdecken.
Aber ich fand's halt auch interessant weil das halt auch wieder so ein daten punkt natürlich geliefert hat weil die halt quasi alle durchgetestet haben und man damit mal so 'ne zahl
so wie viele aktuell infizierte ist denn so in einer stichprobe gibt insofern.
Sag mal war das halt mal ein interessanter datenpunkte und.
Wir können zumindest davon ausgehen dass es in der gesamtbevölkerung wohl kaum mehr sein dürften sondern eher weniger insofern haben wir da.
Auch eine absolute obergrenze.
Denke ich mal gesetzt die auch wiederum spekulationen entgegentritt wir könnten jetzt irgendwie sagen schon mal halb durch immunisiert sein oder so das das zeigt die fußballspiel
du dir definitiv auch dass wir keine so große dunkelziffer haben.
Eine studie liegt hier noch nicht vor also sind jetzt veröffentlichte zahlen der ersten tests es werden
glaube ich auch verschiedene studien im zusammenhang mit diesem durchgehenden test gemacht werden auch antikörper test et cetera von daher sind die,
bundesligaspieler und die ganzen betreuer die ganzen teams auch nochmal besonders unter der lupe und können am ende vielleicht auch noch wiederum interessante wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse liefern.
Definitiv ja und ansonsten kann man natürlich aber auch dieser zahl ich sage mal jeder tausendsiebenhundert wenn man mal davon ausgeht kann man natürlich auch sehr schön jetzt,
mal sich das risiko angucken was also
beim bus oder bahn fahren hast wenn du so ein vollbesetzten bus oder bahn waggon mit hundert.
Passagieren mitreisenden ausgießt dann ja hast du so einmal.
Jeder zehnte bis zwanzigste so bus bahn oder flieger wenn er einigermaßen besetzt ist jeder zwanzigste bus und bahn und wahrscheinlich jeder zehnte flieger,
ja dürfte ein infektiöse sitzen.
Wobei interessanterweise beim fliegen es so ist weil das auch ein.
So ein thema war es kann gut sein dass fliegen weniger.
Riskant ist dass die ansteckungsgefahr geringer ist also es gibt zumindest keine bisher nachgewiesenen
super spreding ereignisse in flugzeugen obwohl
flüge gab wo man dann hinterher festgestellt hat dass einen großteil oder ist ein sehr großer teil der passagiere infiziert war auf dem flug und man dann die anderen
passagiere getrackt hat und festgestellt hat dass es zu keiner ansteckung gekommen ist also es gibt eher anhaltspunkte sagen dass zumindest für für flugzeuge
die ansteckungsgefahr nicht so hoch zu sein scheint
und wüsste aber jetzt nicht ob's ähnliche studien für busse oder bahnen gibt aber jeder kann halt selber überlegen.
Das risiko wie er in das risiko einschätzt
mit jemandem im bus oder in der bahn zu fahren der ansteckend ist mein.
Fazit oder meine risiko abwägung wäre einfach die so busse oder bahnen zu meiden sie aber zu nutzen wenn es denn.
Unbedingt sein muss ja kann man das glaube ich.
Riskieren aber so ich würde nicht zum spaß mit bus oder bahn rumfahren im moment.
Das macht glaube ich so wie.
Leute.
Wenn's wenn's alternativen gift.
Ja fahrrad sogar sogar die hauptstraße jetzt hier bei mir um die ecke die wirklich der fürchterlichste zustand für fahrradfahrer war hat jetzt seine eigene not fahrradspur bekommen hurra endlich.
Ja diese pop-up rad puren und busspuren teilweise schon interessantes phänomen bin gespannt wie viele davon bleiben ich vermute mal es wird noch irgendwie
ja streit geben um die um die dinge aber.
Aber man kann jetzt mal sofort sehen was die auswirkungen davon sind dass nämlich mehr leute fahren das vielleicht auch weiß ich nicht weniger unfälle gibt et cetera pp
und das ist natürlich dann auch so ein bisschen der argumentationskette auf die glaube ich diese ganze fahrrad diskussion bisher dringend gebraucht hat also ich denke gerade in berlin dürfte das größere änderungen nach sich ziehen zumal wir ja hier auch
gerade ein senat haben wir das eigentlich ja anstrebt und in gewisser hinsicht
muss man sagen die gelegenheit jetzt auch genutzt hat mal fakten zu schaffen und mal schauen wie lange die fakten so auf der straße bleiben.
Schauen zu welchem verkehrsverein des führt weil ich kenne also eine stelle zumindest in in kreuzberg da wenn man von von osten
auf dem cotti zufährt so da ist jetzt mal nur dauerstau eigentlich immer fast zu jedem tag und nacht zeit so dauert so zwei drei vier ampelphasen ungefähr
man da auf dem platz kommen weil man fünf bis zehn also schauen wir mal an sich müsste es dazu führen dass die leute anders so lang.
Oder aufs fahrrad umsteigen ich meine wenn die sehen dass man mit dem fahrrad wunderbar schnell voran kommt so weil's jetzt auch sicherer ist meine da wollte man ja vorher auch teilweise gar nicht fahren so aber wenn es jetzt auf einmal ein kompletten abgesperrten freien streifen gibt so.
Dann ändert sich das.
Ist auf jeden fall ein interessantes experiment meine vermutung ist die meisten werden wieder zurückgebaut werden.
Wissen wir nicht kommen wir mal zu deinen weiteren zahlen experimenten weil du hast ja am wochenende auch.
Wieder ein bisschen was getwittert werden uns auch schon drüber unterhalten erzähl doch mal was du da probiert hast und zu welchen ergebnissen du gekommen bist.
Also.
Was ich gemacht habe ist mir jetzt die veröffentlichten daten vom die daten das sind so hundertdreißigtausend.
Setze die so ein bisschen mehr daten enthalten als jetzt täglich nur so und so viele leute erkrankt sondern.
Wo halt.
Zwar nicht jeder fall einzeln aber mal von hundertsechzigtausend fällen so sind mit hundertdreißigtausend datensätzen.
Beschrieben das heißt ein.
Bisschen ist da manchmal kumuliert manchmal hast du halt neun erkrankte in einem datensatz oder so aber die haben dann eben auch sagen die gleichen.
Zusätzlichen daten dazu und da sind steht unter anderem dann auch drin so in welches alter.
In welchem alter welche altersklasse die reinfallen das ist runtergebrochen auf die landkreise so wo die herkommen und.
Was eben besonders interessant ist ist dass das erkrankungen statue und das meldet datum mit drin stehen für jedes jeden.
Dieser ereignisse und so dass
brachte mich dann auf die idee so okay was kann man jetzt schönes mit dem daten machen mal zu gucken was das nämlich mit den daten
macht bis halt dass diese snow casting
und das schöne ist ja da habe ich das die erkrankung daten
drin stehen also der erkrankung zeitpunkt der sollte ja eigentlich unabhängig von irgendwelchen melden verzögerungen sein so egal wie lange es dauert wie lange der test dauert und so wenn jemand das sagt an dem und dem tag habe ich halt
das erste mal symptome verspürt dann sollte das eigentlich nicht wochentags abhängig sein so und das heißt da.
Jetzt stehen nicht sendlich also nicht viel für jeden,
für sechzig prozent ungefähr liegen halt der erkrankungsrisiko punkt vor
wenn man was man da machen kann ist zu sagen die anderen wo der nicht vorliegt dann statistisch zu verteilen wenn man weiß so wie wie lange denn bei denen
wo der erkrankung zeitpunkt vorliegt wie lange das gedauert hat bis zur meldung dann kann man da halt sagen so eine.
Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung teilung machen und dann verteilt man die wo man es nicht weiß entsprechend auf die datenstaus die man.
Aber das sind jetzt alles fallzahlen oder das infektionsbad zahlen also ist das jetzt die liste der infizierten oder ist es die liste der erkrankten.
Die liste der infizierten und dadurch.
Es sind natürlich auch welche die eventuell nicht erkrankt sind dabei das weiß man jetzt nicht genau aber es ist sagen die liste der positiv getesteten so wäre wahrscheinlich die genaue.
Also es sind die infizierten wo ein teil erkrankt sind und wir wissen aber jetzt nicht also die daten geben es nicht her also da steht jetzt nicht drin ist nicht erkrankt sondern es ist nur kein erkrankt.
Kein erkrankung datum.
Drin warum auch immer entweder weil es nicht erfasst wurde oder was vergessen wurde fast zu werden oder weil gar keine erkrankung vorlag.
Genau kannst ganzheit verschiedene gründe vergeben warum das datum nicht da ist.
Ist aber eigentlich schon ein bisschen blöd eigentlich dass die daten das nicht hergeben weil diese information müsste ja eigentlich auch vorliegen.
Ja aber wie gesagt es gibt also einen teil der fälle da
ist es sehr wahrscheinlich so ungefähr fünf bis größenordnung fünf prozent der fälle da liegt das erkrankungen tum nach dem meldedaten was.
Vorkommen kann entweder ist es ein tippfehler.
Oder es ist tatsächlich so dass die leute erst getestet wurden aber zu dem zeitpunkt noch keine symptome hatten und die krankheit bei denen sei erst nach dem test ausgebrochen ist wobei eigentlich ja.
Auch die maßgaben wer getestet werden soll ich symptome vorausgesetzt haben aber eben nicht bei allen es gab dann offensichtlich auch leute die getestet wurden obwohl sie noch keine symptome hatten aber das.
Aber sie kontakt hatten weil sie einfach mit getestet wurden.
So
Das ist jetzt eine vermutung von dir das gibt jetzt keine offizielle erklärung die an diesem daten dran steht dass das genau das meint.
Es ist halt es ist halt einfach nur sagt keine erkrankung datum da und.
Ja eigentlich dachte ich ich könnte dann ganz schön habe ich dann auch erstmal gemacht auf basis der erkrankung daten also.
Alle umverteilen und dann auszurechnen okay zu einem tag x
wie viel meldungen sind reingekommen zu einem bestimmten erkrankungen tag und wie viele kam dann noch wieviel tage später also sozusagen auch nochmal zu gucken wie viel prozent an jedem tag
waren denn da anmeldungen und dann das zu benutzen um sowas zu machen wie die now cast vom das problem ist nur dass ich dann festgestellt habe.
Mit den daten dampf die mir vorliegen die halt com unterträglich rausgespielt werden vom.
Das,
nur datensätze sind die sich auf den aktuellen und den vortrag beziehen beziehungsweise es fehlt das datum in dem datensatz wann.
Ist die meldung gezählt worden also wann ist sie beim in die offizielle statistik,
eingegangen wann war sagen meldeschlusszeit für diese meldung und das weiß man nur für die meldung die am
aktuellen tag und am vortag reingekommen sind da kennt man den meldeschlusszeit für alle anderen meldungen die.
Davor reingekommen ist musste man den daten dampf vom vortag kennen es gibt aber kein veröffentlichtes archiv und weil ich erst.
Von der woche damit angefangen habe habe ich jetzt auch erst auch dank noch jemandem auf twitter so der mir noch zwei fehlende dampfe dass ich jetzt eine woche habe an an damms und
damit schon mal dann rechnen kann.
Es gibt keinen das macht mich jetzt noch ein bisschen fassungslos die daten sind immer nur tagesaktuell und ändern sich dann am laufenden meter und es gibt kein archiv der letzten daten obwohl man genau die bräuchte um die volle information herauslesen können.
So ist es so.
Mann ey oh gott.
Fairerweise muss man sagen sie versprechen auch nicht mehr also die überschrift lautet auch genauso irgendwie veränderungen.
Das kommt aber einem daten löschen gleich.
Ja das hat was von daten löschen.
Aber es gibt ja auch keine zeit rein von den gemeldeten daten da gibt's ja auch nur immer die vom aktuellen tag das heißt selbst da sind müssen leute halt die aktuellen tages daten.
Oder eintragen also wikipedia ist die einzige quelle wenn man jetzt die daten als zeitreihe haben.
Okay also falls uns jemand zuhört der diese daten vielleicht täglich gebäck gehabt hat so hätten wir gerne.
Wobei die auch teilweise ich meine die sind haben auch teilweise mehr felder reingenommen und sie haben sich wohl auch im laufe der zeit ein bisschen verbessert.
Ja und wenn wir uns ja und wenn uns vielleicht zufällig jemand zuhört der damit mit dem daten sport zu tun hat oder irgendwie also es wäre
wirklich ganz ganz toll entweder sagen das archiv der vergangenen daten
oder falls es in der datenbank drin ist und ich hoffe und gehe eigentlich davon aus dass die datenbank struktur so ist einfach das datum wann der datensatz vielleicht,
das erste mal angelegt wurde und wann er das letzte mal geändert wurde so
das wären halt auch schon mal super
hilfreiche dinge weil so kannst du aus diesem datensatz aus den hundertsechzig daten kannst du die offizielle zeitreihe der meldung nicht genau rekonstruieren du hast dann daten die weichen aber natürlich dann
bisschen plus minus nach oben und unten meistens eher eher nach oben weichen die halt von den offiziellen meldet zahlen ab und es kann
eigentlich nicht sein dass man das nicht nachrechnen kann das also ja bitte bitte.
Naja also an der stelle müsste man vielleicht auch mal generell mal drüber sprechen.
Jetzt auch mit ein paar leuten so nebenbei noch gechattet mal so ein bisschen gefragt so ja die sie also auch so mit datenauswertung beschäftigen die er sich auch teilweise auf diese daten
gestürzt habe und die hatten auch ein paar schlimme sachen zu berichten bis hin zu so sachen wie das,
datum mal so und mal mal indem man mal in dem format vorliegt also dass da einfach auch die datenqualität in sich also rein vom format her schon schlecht ist schreibt man irgendwelche
diese daten dann importiert und dann ändert sich die darstellung des datums man ist einfach das geht einfach nicht.
Damit kommt man noch noch klar dass kostet natürlich auch zeit,
natürlich auch macht es halt auch unnötig schwieriger aber grundsätzlich ja kriegt man das eigentlich einigermaßen hin.
Aber was man halt nicht rekonstruieren kann ist halt wenn ja wenn die daten fehlen plus warum,
das jetzt auch nach also es ist halt dann irgendwie nach landkreisen sortiert das ganze so das erschließt sich mir auch jetzt nicht unbedingt wer ja egal.
Mach doch mal ein paar vorschläge wie es sein sollte ich meine wenn uns jetzt jemand zuhört dann können wir ja auch gleich wünscht dir was spielen meine daten formate und und und ich meine gerade so
einfache sachen wie zahlen reihen ich meine wir reden ja hier nicht von irgendeinem hexenwerk und drei d modell ja mit schildern und was nicht alles wir reden hier wirklich von zahlen kolonnen
würde ich auch seit zwanzig jahren einfach einen gelöstes problem und jeder der sich irgendwie auch ansatzweise mit zahlen beschäftigt also daten die über die zeit sich ergeben und die vor allem auch korrekturen in die vergangenheit machen,
das ist ja so ein klassisches problem weiß einfach dass es dann eben einfach bestimmte metadaten bedarf um daraus.
Korrekt was herauszurechnen und meine wozu sind denn diese daten damit wir uns alle ein bild machen können und wenn die daten ist aber an sich schon nicht hergeben also wenn einfach nicht genug informationen da drin sind um sich dieses bild machen zu können
kann man auch fragen was was sollen denn die daten überhaupt in dieser form.
Also eigentlich sagen was ich mir wünschen würde wie gesagt entweder die ganzen dampf aus der vergangenheit beziehungsweise
möglichst eigentlich neue dampf mit dem stand der vergangenheit oder halt
einfach diese metadaten halt gesagt wann ist der datensatz reingekommen oder eine eine einheitliche für den datensatz oder diese übermittlung dass man die halt dann noch zuordnen kann
und es fehlen auch felder wo aus meiner sicht
es ist natürlich auch immer eine frage sozusagen von gefährdet man vielleicht die privatsphäre so datenschutz aber das sind halt aggregiert fälle das sind so zahlen gut da steht denn jetzt noch geschlecht dabei
und so und altersbereich aber da stehen halt keine namen oder adressen oder oder sonst irgendwas drin und.
Eigentlich werden eben auch die symptome erfasst so aber auch anhand sag mal einer vorgegebenen liste und ich finde
die könnten sie auch ruhig mit da reinpacken
und weiß nicht welche felder es sonst noch so gibt aber ich würde mir schon wünschen einfach wenn das irgendwelche zahlen veröffentlicht dass sie das machen wie das gute wissenschaftler heutzutage tun
und halt die rohdaten soweit zur verfügung stellen wie sie es denn können zumindest insoweit dass es möglich ist das nachzuvollziehen des nachzuberichten so das gehört eigentlich
zum guten ton dazu qualitäts- schaft ja aber diesen teil von qualitätswein schaft der ist noch nicht so ganz
angekommen.
Ja hoffen wir mal dass ich das noch besser bin vielleicht ein bisschen mehr mehr luft ist für alle aber es gibt ja auch viele beispiele aus anderen ländern ich habe da so einen link bekommen wie daten aufbereitet werden zum beispiel in holland.
Wo eben aus diesen daten auch noch solche erhebungen hervorging mit welcher altersgruppe hat welche altersgruppe angesteckt also hat er richtig so ein vektor mit hat infiziert ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt auf die zwischen den einzelnen.
Fallen fallen eine information ist die da drauf ist so mit dieser hat dieser angesteckt ist vermutlich mal nicht aber du hast zumindest solche informationen mit welches alter hat welches alter angesteckt wo man dann sehen kann.
Das ist mehr oder weniger gleichmäßig verteilt ist also sozusagen gleichaltrige sich immer noch.
Die höchste wahrscheinlichkeit dass man angesteckt wird ist in holland zumindest von gleichaltrigen weil man mit dem wahrscheinlich am meisten zu tun hat.
Ja so sieht das das auch in in deutschland auf jeden fall auch aussehen und das wäre natürlich das wäre natürlich auch super interessant ich weiß nur noch nicht.
Überhaupt das selber die die daten hat ob es da überhaupt eine elektronische übermittlung.
Wie die fälle denn miteinander zusammenhängen ja also weil wenn ich gesundheitsämtern gehe ich mal davon aus die wissen halt schon zum teil wer wen angesteckt hat.
Die kerntätigkeit des contact tracing ist ja genau das herauszufinden.
Genau so aber ich hab da gerade so ein bisschen meine zweifel
dass diese daten auch elektronisch zentral erfasst und gemeldet werden beziehungsweise
wenn dann nur innerhalb einzelner gesundheitsämtern wenn deren system des hergibt aber ich glaube das zentrale daten sammelsystemen vom
glaube ich kann das nicht so an der stelle sind wir dann natürlich doch durchaus
bei der frage von datenschutz und privatsphäre weil wenn ich.
Sagen jetzt dann grafen hab inwieweit kann ich dann eventuell identitäten aufdecken oder so
also müsste man halt schon gucken aber ich glaube sie stehen bestimmt auf papier irgendwo.
Also wir sind da auf jeden fall offen für eure kommentare falls ihr da irgendwelche hinweise habt entweder wo eben daten noch rumliegen die noch nicht gesehen haben oder.
Wie denn so die daten realität tatsächlich ist ich hoffe auch dass ich in einer anderen sendung hier naher zukunft da auch nochmal andere perspektive noch mit beleuchten kann.
Gut jetzt sind wir jetzt durch mit den zahlen rasen noch eine anmerkung.
Ich würde sagen wir machen ausland machen wir machen wir dann nächste woche so ich hatte
angefangen auf dein wunsch hin so ein paar spezielle länder nochmal mehr anzuschauen aber ich bin noch nicht durch.
Und dann machen wir nächste woche vielleicht dann den internationalen rundumschlag auch was schweden betrifft und so weiter.
Usa genau ja das auch ganz interessant ist zumal ja da eben auch anders umgegangen wird mit den sperrungen beziehungsweise jetzt auch die lok downs dort schon greifen und da tut sich gerade so einiges was für uns auch nochmal interessante,
liefern könnte für den umgang mit der ganzen virus situation in den nächsten zukunft.
Ja auf eine sache vielleicht noch am rande weil wir uns ja auch immer wieder so mit
fragen auch immer wieder angeklungen sind hier und natürlich die ganze debatte jetzt im moment so ein bisschen in richtung wirtschaft versus gesundheit läuft.
Sagen wenn wir wieder dinge
loslassen aber ich habe da unter anderem noch ein ganz interessantes interview auf das mich jemand auf twitter aufmerksam gemacht hat ich soll hätte mir
egal den namen raussuchen sollen damit ich das hier sagen kann auf jeden fall danke dafür mit dem leiter des dortmunder gesundheitsamts der da so ein bisschen interviewt wird ich weiß nicht ob du das.
Das habe ich das habe ich gesehen ja genau das der immer verlangen ja den interview ich weiß aber jetzt auch nicht ganz genau wie heiß ich schlage das mal kurz nach erzähl erstmal.
Ja und den bemerkenswerten punkt natürlich jetzt rein aus sicht der gesundheitsämtern ist die sind ja nicht nur für corvette
zuständig sondern es gibt halt auch noch andere krankheiten und es gibt auch psychische gesundheit und
es gibt halt jetzt nicht direkt die gesundheitsrelevanter aber die kindeswohl fragen zum beispiel und es gibt natürlich dann die situation in der pflege so das heißt.
Bei all diesen mal lok down geschichten oder einschränkungen geschichten und natürlich auch wirtschaft
ist natürlich dummerweise auch mit gesundheit verknüpft so leute die plötzlich in existenzieller not
sind oder angst haben so entwickeln natürlich auch
eventuell bestimmte krankheiten psychischer art oder teilweise können die sich auch physisch manifestieren dann ist es wohl so dass im moment
keine hausbesuche so um.
Auf das kindeswohl zu achten so vom jugendamt aus im moment stattfinden so das heißt das ist wohl auch ein riesenproblem und das gerade auch in der zeit so kindesmissbrauch einmal wo
irgendwie auch noch alle leute zuhause sind und man davon ausgeht dass es dadurch vielleicht eigentlich mehr probleme geben müsste gleichzeitig gibt es da keine keine kontrolle und so und dass man wirklich ganz also unabhängig davon
jetzt wie man so der die debatte also sein geld versus gesundheit sieht
ist es halt schon auch eine frage von gesundheit des ein- und gesundheit des anderen und das
war so ein so ein punkt den man einfach auch immer wieder sich
ins gedächtnis rufen sollte und das ist aber natürlich eine super schwierige abwägung weil das natürlich sagen man gut auf der einen seite.
Konkrete zahlen hat oder immer konkreter werdende gefährdungen auf der anderen seite natürlich dann
bei den folgen des shutdown man noch mehr im dunkeln agiert also alles gerade eine ganz ganz schwierige geschichte aber man kann auf jeden fall schon mal festhalten.
Das gesundheitliche folgen auf jeden fall auch da sind
so aber dann hat man natürlich auch wieder die frage okay lieber jetzt irgendwie schnell runter und dann wieder aufmachen oder lassen wir es halt langsam laufen das spielt natürlich auch in die ganzen gesundheitsschäden
mit rein und ja also schwierige debatte wo ich.
Auf jeden fall darauf gestoßen bin also man kann es sollte das nicht schwarz weiß man sollte jetzt nicht sagen irgendwie ja auch nur ein
corona toter mehr so darf nicht sein sondern da schüttet man dann das kind auch wieder mit dem bade aus.
Link ist auf jeden fall den shownotes doktor frank renken ist der leiter des ganzen das ist
interessantes interview geht so eine dreiviertel stunde dabei gibt es auch noch ein paar andere aspekte weil er sich ja auch dazu äußert wie die gesundheitsämtern.
Generell so arbeiten beziehungsweise was du seine einschätzung ist wer denn hier gut vorbereitet gewesen ist und wer nicht also dabei
kommt im wesentlichen raus ja also in dortmund selber saß ganz gut aus
weil das ihnen die stadt ermöglicht hat immer noch ein personal überhang hatten also mehr personal hatten in diesem infektionsbad nach verfolgungs- bereich und dementsprechend da gut gerüstet waren dass er eben teilweise bei gesundheitsämtern aufm land
ganz anders aussieht und jetzt da auch entsprechende taskforces gegründet werden um dann eben,
wenn fall verfolgung größerer ordnung ansteht dann personelle verstärkung von der stadt ins land,
geht ne also auch interessante abwägung an der stelle wo gesundheitsämtern gut ausgestattet sind wo nicht auch die digitale frage wurde.
Angesprochen da tut sich jetzt was also man merkt dass das.
Alle jetzt langsam verstehen dass es auch so mit der ganzen digitalisierung ein wenig der nacharbeit.
Gut wäre ein wunder wenn sich da jetzt nichts tun würde aber ja aber es ist.
Die art von wunder die haben wir in deutschland öfter du weiß ich noch nicht.
Gut.
Ja okay also es war jedenfalls fand ich noch so ein erwähnenswert der punkt wo was in der vergangenen woche da so aufgeschlagen ist an dingen und dann können wir glaube ich zum contact tracing langsam.
Genau ich meine ist im prinzip eine interessante brücke an dieser stelle weil gesundheitsämtern bedeutet natürlich auch contact tracing und haben's ja auch letztes mal schon gesagt und ich habe auch das gefühl langsam verfestigt sich das so ein bisschen in dieser ganzen debatte.
Contact tracing sind begriff der eigentlich erst mit dieser diskussion der apps hochkam und alle alle so ein bisschen die wahrnehmung hatten und ich muss auch sagen auch.
Auch ich am anfang so contact tracing das ist jetzt sozusagen was neues so das.
Das machen jetzt smartphones so und jetzt schnüffeln sie uns hinterher und das ist glaube ich ein blick auf diese situation die man etwas
abstreifen sollte und man muss einfach betonen contact tracing ist etwas was gesundheitsämtern tun das ist sozusagen der normale
vorgang der fall nach verfolgung infektionsweg werde brechen außen es geht ja jetzt auch nicht nur so für den korona virus sondern es gilt natürlich genauso auch für masern und alle anderen sachen tuberkulose also nicht nur viren.
Alle ansteckenden krankheiten die in irgendeiner form meldepflichtig sind und die potentielle bedrohung für die bevölkerung darstellen werden mit kontakt tracing verfolgt
das ist einfach das was gesundheitsämtern tun nur sie tun es eben manuell da gibt es ausgebildete leute.
Die wissen wie sie zu fragen haben die wissen wonach sie zu fragen haben und zwar nicht nur weil sie eine liste durchgehen sondern weil sie dementsprechend geschult sind tragen das dann
ja
idealerweise datenbanken ein und sind vor allem viel am telefon die rufen halt an und recherchieren diesen ganzen fällen hinterher sind da wohl auch ganz fix und wissen im idealfall halt auch wie sie mit den leuten umgehen müssen damit sie diese informationen auch bekommen.
Die ganze debatte um die apps ist halt jetzt eine debatte um wie kann man diesen vorgang unterstützen wie kann man,
dinge verbessern wo diese gesundheitsämtern generell schlechtere karten haben so das ist natürlich vor allem zwei bereiche den einen haben wir ja glaube ich auch schon ausreichend gewürdigt es ist halt
die geschwindigkeit dieses virus die eben jetzt neue anforderungen stellt weil typischerweise war es bisher immer so in dem moment wo jemand
ein krankheitssymptomen gezeigt hat dann liegt dieser infektionsweg zeitpunkt nicht so lange zurück
die krankheit greift schnell auf ein übermannt bemerkt dass man sich,
angesteckt hat ich habe jetzt keine zahlen wie sehr das bei einzelnen anderen viren etcetera sich genau verteilt und wie das so ist aber.
Ist es ja klar saskia zwei das ist viel diskutiert worden dass man einfach so lange schon ansteckend sein kann vier fünf sechs tage bevor man symptome bekommt wenn man sie überhaupt bekommen ist ein problem weil man natürlich hier nochmal extra zeit verliert.
Das andere ding ist natürlich dass man auch in dem besten contact tracing einer befragung leute nur informationen entlocken können die sie halt auch wissen.
Mit wem hast du ab
mit wem hast du zeit verbracht mit wem wohnst du zusammen wo sind die etcetera wer war noch auf dieser geschäftsreise wer war bei diesem essen anwesend all diese ganzen,
dinge aber du weißt vielleicht mit wem du essen warst aber du weißt ja nicht wie hinter dir saß da ist ja nicht mehr am nachbartisch war mit wem du dich in irgendeine schlange reingedrängelt hast etcetera.
Und all diese ganzen.
Fälle würde man halt ganz gerne auch natürlich wissen aber woher soll man diese information nehmen und da kommt dann halt diese ganze sache mit den apps rein,
und das ist sozusagen die diskussion die da geführt werden muss wollte das jetzt einfach nochmal so voranstellen weil diese ganze erwartungshaltung.
Auch ein bisschen überzogen ist ne also ich sage ja auch ja immer ich bin relativ optimistisch was was die wirksamkeit dieser apps betrifft,
aber das heißt nicht dass ich sage ich bin relativ optimistisch dass diese apps uns alle retten werden
ich sag nur ich bin relativ optimistisch dass sie einen beitrag dazu liefern können dass das normale contact tracing dadurch verbessert wird weil man einfach leute auf einmal mit
hineinziehen kann die sonst überhaupt nicht berücksichtigt worden wären weil einfach die information darüber nicht da ist und weil man eben die chance hat diese prozesse auch zu beschleunigen
das ist eigentlich diese beiden faktoren die glaube ich an dieser stelle wichtig sind.
Konkret ist aber auch neues passiert apple und google haben
ihre api jetzt nicht nur noch ein weiteres mal weiter genauer spezifiziert und teilweise auch ziemlich umgebaut es gibt jetzt auch releases
da ich das etwas näher verfolge berichte ich das jetzt immer so ein bisschen aus dieser apple perspektive aber apple und google sind hier eigentlich synchronisiert das heißt immer wenn es heißt es gibt einen release dann
findet das auch bei beiden statt und die spezifikation werden ja sowieso von beiden.
Einheitlich gepflegt also es gibt da nicht die eine und die andere spezifikation und es tut sich da und da mal was sollen die gehen hier wirklich sehr konsequent gemeinsam vor
und natürlich sehen programmierer schnittstellen auf dem einen betriebssystem anders aus als auf dem
anderen aber sie tun dasselbe und sie bewegen sich um dieselbe abstraktion herum.
Jetzt gab es eigentlich zweierlei dinge also apple hat bitte version von dem bereitgestellt dreizehn,
punkt fünf das ist sogar ein bisschen umbenannt worden wahrscheinlich genau wegen dieser tracing denn normalerweise wäre das jetzt nur so ein back fixt release
gewesen es wurde also bis vor kurzem noch unter der version dreizehn vier fünf,
gehandelt und jetzt ist es halt dreizehn fünf wenn sie auf der zweiten stelle was ändert dann gibt's halt immer neue pur mir schnittstellen das ist ja hier der fall
und davon gibt es halt jetzt auch eine richtige beta vision das heißt entwickler können seit einigen tagen ganz konkret diese software auf ihren telefon laufen lassen.
Testen und gegen diese programmieren das heißt nicht dass jetzt alle entwickler in der lage sind auch eine entsprechende app zu releasen dem wird nicht so sein sondern nach wie vor ist halt vorgesehen es wird pro land,
oder sagen wir mal pro zuständigkeitsbereich einer oberen gesundheitsbehörde was in unserem fall halt identisch ist mit land eine app zugelassen werden.
Und die unterliegt auch bestimmten.
Vorgaben und einschränkungen und zusätzlich wurde aber auch
sample code veröffentlicht es wurden so mock-ups gemacht also quasi so sketches von user interface so könnte ihr programm aussehen und entsprechende,
guidelines wie man da am besten vorgehen soll im prinzip existiert so ein kompletter baukasten und man muss noch nicht mal viel können um daraus schnell so eine app zu machen die das minimum tut.
Und das ist überhaupt aber ganz lustig in unserer ganzen diskussion die wir derzeit haben das immer alle sagen so ja die app und so und es voll schwierig das zu entwickeln
ja das ganze vorhaben hat eine gewisse komplexität.
Aber die liegt nicht auf dem telefon weil das was diese app auf dem telefon machen muss das ist einerseits extrem reglementiert andererseits handelt es sich hier um.
Relativ wenig was überhaupt getan werden muss auf dem telefon weil die hauptarbeit macht eigentlich das betriebssystem schon für ein und die app kommt eigentlich nur an und liefert daten oder holt daten ab.
Und man kann also jetzt relativ schnell das machen was halt wirklich,
aufwendig ist und was die hauptaufgabe eigentlich ist dieser teams die jetzt dran sitzen ist eben genau diese integration in das jeweilige gesundheitssystem und das bedeutet natürlich in unserem fall
wie kann man eben jetzt mit den gesundheitsämtern zusammenarbeiten und zwar wahrscheinlich mit allen und wie kann man das mit den test instituten den labors etcetera verbinden also wie bildet man die realität des gesundheitssystems
letztlich ab um diese apps an diesem prozess des kontakt tracing anzubinden.
Beziehungsweise vor allem erstmal auch an das testsystem anzubinden aber es gibt ja viele überlegungen wie man das dann eben auch noch weiter kombinieren kann.
Ja das heißt da muss jetzt vor allem viel geleistet werden und das ist natürlich erforderlich dass da viel miteinander geredet wird.
Das ganze hat jetzt interessante guidelines bekommen.
Also apple google sagen so ja okay das könnt ihr jetzt machen aber
haben sie eine ganze liste von bedingungen gemacht mit einigen konnte man rechnen bei anderen war es nicht so ganz klar
wie denn das alles laufen würde also wenn man jetzt diese app installiert dann muss du halt der user gefragt werden nochmal nach der installation okay
dieses diese äpfel jetzt hier quasi auf diese tracing daten zugreifen um hier eine benachrichtigung machen zu können darf die das also da muss halt explizit nochmal
ja gesagt werden so das ganz interessant ist ist dass das eigentliche feature des aussenden von all dies und das empfangen von addis also dieses darunterliegende,
das ist so jetzt designt worden und ich vermute mal so wird es auch kommen dass wenn man jetzt das betriebssystem-update macht.
Und das telefon kommt wieder hoch dass dieses feature eingeschaltet ist.
Ja wo man sich ja denkt so oh hier privatsphäre und so weiter datenschutz und.
Was erlaube apple und google ja nur das ding ist und da haben wir ja viel schon darüber geredet weil dieses protokoll.
Von vornherein so designt ist dass es eigentlich so so wird so ein klassisches privacy bei design ist also es tut etwas was erstmal niemand irgendetwas sagt aus dem man irgendwas nennenswert ableiten kann.
Meine auffassung nach aber auch der auffassung viele andere leute übrigens kann man das halt einfach einschalten.
Und hat den vorteil dass man im prinzip ab dem moment wo man ein update macht das telefon in einem zustand ist wo es schon mal anfängt all dieses ganze.
Absuchen der umgebung und das aussenden der eigenen zufällig erzeugten addis einfach schon mal betreibt.
So dass man die app die app zwei wochen später installieren kann und die app findet sozusagen daten schon vor.
Darauf muss man dann nochmal ja sagen man muss dann sagen okay jetzt will ich aber auch wirklich an diesem globalen oder zumindest.
Land globalen datenaustausch teilhaben ja aber man verliert keine zeit dadurch,
die apps wiederum haben also.
Einschränkungen und man muss halt sagen ja ich will das erlauben dass die app das überhaupt dass sie sich überhaupt mal einklinken darf und es wird natürlich auch vorgeschrieben dass wenn man jetzt positiv getestet wurde dass wenn die daten hochgeladen wird dass man das auch nochmal.
Muss et cetera es gibt vorschriften dass sie eben auch keine anderen daten sammeln dürfen als die die,
notwendig sind und vor allem wird auch vorgeschrieben dass diese apps keinen zugriff auf location datum bekommen.
Das ist ja so ein schwieriger bereich der wenn wir nachher nochmal vielleicht drauf eingehen aber es gibt.
Quasi von vornherein schon mal diese restriktion also selbst wenn die programme des darein programmieren würden sie würden einfach gar nicht in den app store gelassen werden ja oder die erhalten überhaupt gar nicht das fleck das ja auch nur danach fragen dürfen,
das wird
wird den sozusagen von vornherein verboten sei sollen einfach nur diese all dies einsammeln und die nicht mit irgendetwas korrelieren kein zugriff auf kontakte kein zugriff auf andere daten die in irgendeiner form diese identität in diese daten wieder reinspielen können
da kann man sich jetzt wahrscheinlich viel einfallen lassen und unter umständen musst du auch nochmal nachgearbeitet werden aber man sieht in welche richtung das geht die wollen halt das
erlauben dass man diese modifizierung.
Benutzt also wir wollen sich dadurch keinerlei hintertürchen lassen und das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut sie schließen auch die nutzung für
strafverfolgung aus sie schließen auch explizit bestrafungsaktion aus für zum beispiel quarantäne verstöße oder sowas all das darf
damit nicht kombiniert werden.
Auch noch nicht mal also auch nicht zur quarantäne erzwingen oder kontrolle.
Interessante vorgaben und was natürlich auch bemerkenswert ist apple hat und google haben natürlich den daumen
drauf apple ein bisschen mehr als google so weil bei google kann man ja auch aus beliebigen stores
sachen installieren ohne den siegen von google bei apple geht es halt nicht das heißt selbst wenn sich.
Irgendwie eine behörde dann entscheiden sollte keine ahnung irgendwas irgendwie dagegen zu verstoßen.
So kann apple die aus dem store schmeißen.
Also diese guidelines sind nicht nicht ohne so muss man muss man sagen.
Tja allerdings.
Aber sie erlauben eben auch die entwicklung dieser apps also es ist jetzt auch nicht so dass jetzt irgendwelche hürden aufgestellt haben um dieses eigentliche ziel nicht zu erreichen ganz im gegenteil sie liefern eine ganze menge nach.
Schauen wir mal was ich technisch konkret noch geändert hat weil es gab auch nochmal ein update dieser spezifikation.
Das ging dann jetzt in den letzten zwei wochen halt relativ schnell jetzt sind wir bei version eins zwei.
Und man merkt aber auch dass man so langsam in die zielgerade einbiegen nicht nur weil es jetzt schon software release gab sondern auch weil sich eben der essenzielle teil als wir es letzte mal hier die änderung diskutiert haben hatte sich ja tatsächlich an dem.
An dem ganzen krypto und also was wirklich an daten rübergeschickt wird et cetera also das was
oliver der hin und her geschickt wird das hatte sich ja nochmal geändert haben sie noch mal drüber nachgedacht haben graphik angepasst und haben noch mehr daten reingemacht etcetera
das ist aber jetzt offensichtlich dann also das das es steht jetzt quasi fest und jetzt haben sie ja quasi auch das erste release gemacht das halt ab jetzt alle daten die jetzt gesammelt werden so,
für für die nächste zeit ich hatte ja erwähnt steht eine version nummer drin also sie haben immer noch die möglichkeit zu sagen okay wir ändern nochmal das,
aber dann ist es auch erkennbar dass es geändert wird aber erstmal gibt es keine änderung was sie aber geändert haben.
Ist die akp hatte ich ja schon erwähnt also die art und weise wie eine app jetzt auf diese subsystemen zugreift und wie sie vor allem diese überprüfung ob
denn ein kontakt stattgefunden hat mit einer veröffentlichten wie das jetzt eigentlich vonstatten geht also das abi hat sich da,
grundlegend geändert alles heißt auf einmal anders und die abfolge der funktion parameter et cetera ich habe sie sich aufs letzte verglichen aber
wenn man sich dann ein blick auf die beiden dokumente sieht sofort so wo vorher fünfzehn einträge waren sind jetzt irgendwie nur noch zehn und heißen irgendwie alle anders
und es gibt eine.
Zentrale grundsätzliche änderung und zwar haben sie jetzt nämlich eine andere oder eine etwas genauere definition wie diese sogenannte exporter detects stattfinden kann
nochmal zur erinnerung das system soll ja so funktionieren jemand wird positiv getestet.
Hatte im idealfall die letzten vierzehn tage diese app oder beziehungsweise ein telefon mit diesem protokoll laufend dabei.
Hat also im prinzip überall wo man lange laufen ist seine hinterlassen und andere haben diese all dies eingesammelt.
Jetzt veröffentliche ich mit dieser app.
Nach meinem test kriegst und freischalten und der sorgt dann dafür dass alle anderen telefone auf einmal meine codes der letzten vierzehn tage sehen.
Ich habe es noch nicht so hundertprozentig verstanden ob man wenn man das runterlädst wirklich sieht dass es ein,
ein mensch und hier sind die daten der letzten vierzehn tage sind oder ob es wirklich vierzehn nicht voneinander trennbare tage sind habe ich noch nicht so hundertprozentig verstanden tut aber auch erstmal
glaube ich nichts zur sache ist glaube ich in beiden fällen eigentlich egal.
Und dann nimmt man also diese kies aus dem man ja dann für den jeweiligen tag all diese wieder errechnen kann die man unter umständen vielleicht gesehen hat,
die app nimmt also dann diese kies und sag hier hör mal,
ich habe hier kies für dich dieser diagnose kies die mir gerade aus dem internet zugespielt wurden guck doch mal ob ich jetzt hier mit irgendeinem von denen.
In in der nähe war also ob diese all dies gesehen wurden und prüft doch auch mal bitte.
Denn deine auffassung nach hier ein kontakt stattgefunden hat der jetzt im sinne dieses contact tracing im sinne dieser
gefahren einschätzungen bin ich hier zu nahe zu lange zu nahe gewesen irgendwie die relevanten kriterien erfüllt das ist sozusagen dieser vorgang um den,
es jetzt hier geht und der wurde als jetzt sehr genau beschrieben und bisher ist ja in dieser ganzen debatte immer nur über bluetooth geredet worden ja bluetooth
haben wir ja auch schon ausreichend diskutiert bluetooth energy
funk die ganze zeit rum und da ist dann derjenige der sendet sendet seine signalstärke und dem moment wo man die aldi empfängt dann
speichert man auch nochmal ab mit welcher intensität man das gehabt also man gewinnt so ein rahmendaten für wie weit irgendwas weg war aber da steht jetzt nicht wirklich eine meterzahl drin
und selbst wenn sie da drin stehen würde wissen wir ja auch auch breit diskutiert und kritisiert wurden allerorten fängt es halt bestimmte fälle nicht ab
man weiß nicht weil er jetzt eine glasscheibe dazwischen oder eine wand oder eine plastikfolie ja wie gut war ich geschützt all diese ganzen anderen rahmendaten
kann einfach so ein bluetooth system nicht nicht wissen woher auch ja.
Und tatsächlich ist es jetzt so dass in diesem technischen vorgang wenn die app sagt so hier ist der kiez bitte check mal auf kontakt diese ganze bluetooth sache.
Einer von vier kriterien ist es gibt also vier grundlegende parameter die jetzt überprüft werden.
Das ist halt einerseits eben dieser.
Bluetooth wert also man kann sagen diese signalstärke bitte berücksichtigen diese signalstärke nicht mehr berücksichtigen.
Es gibt einen zweiten parameter der ein risiko für den jeweiligen tag enthält weil wenn
ich mich jetzt melde und dann ist auch klar ich war erkrankt an dem dem tag kann man ja dann auch den einzelnen tagen ein risiko zuweisen wenn man weiß okay
ein tag vorher vor der erkrankung und die zwei tage danach ist man wahrscheinlich extrem infektiös aber eine woche später halt nicht mal so sehr.
Und diese informationen können jetzt vom gesundheitssystem mit der veröffentlichung dieses tests auch.
Dieser meldung beigefügt werden und ich kann dann eben diese daten nehmen und die fließen auch in diese bewertung mit rein.
Der dritte parameter der getestet wird ist die dauer also man kann dann auch sagen okay das war jetzt weniger als fünf minuten oder das waren fünf minuten oder es waren zehn fünfzehn zwanzig fünfundzwanzig
dreißig minuten oder mehr als das auch das kann eben auch nochmal unterschiedlich gewichtet werden.
Und zusätzlich zu den.
Verhältnismäßig technischen parametern gibt es dann auch noch ein ganz allgemein gehaltenen sogenannten transmissionswärmeverlust parameter der in gar keiner form jetzt 'ne technische grundlage hat sondern wo einfach nur gesagt wird.
Es gibt hier die einschätzung des gesundheitsamtes das bei diesem kontakt folgendes risiko bestand.
Was auch immer das sein mag ja also es kann ja zum beispiel sein dass man weiß an diesem tag.
Wenn man das ermittelt hat ja weil was gesundheitsamtes ermittelt hat in einem interview weiß man was diese person getan hat.
Man weiß sie ist irgendwie die ganze zeit schreien nackt spucken und husten irgendwie durch durch eine gaststätte gelaufen so ja.
Oder eben auch genau das gegenteil und diese einschätzung kann man dann auch wiederum für jeden tag hier noch mit dazu packen.
Jeder dieser parameter ist jetzt in in so einem spektrum von acht stufen abgebildet.
Also sowohl für parameter a b c d nenne ich die jetzt mal hast du acht stufen.
Die teilweise eben vorgegeben sind also bei dem bluetooth sind es eben verschiedene signalstärke gruppen bei dem tagesreise ist es eben
welches risiko bestand vor vierzehn tagen welches risiko bestand am zwölften und dreizehnten tag bestand am zehnten elften tag immer so zwei a perlchen ne bis zum zu heute und im letzten tag
und wie schon erwähnt bei der dauer halt auch so fünf minuten blöcke
und genauso auch bei diesem allgemeinen risiko ding hast du also auch diese acht stufe und du kannst aber jetzt als app sagen.
Wie du je die jeweilige einzelne stufe gewichten möchtest.
Also es ist gar nicht mehr so dass diese automatisch soliden ja sind sondern du kannst halt sagen alles was kleiner als fünf minuten kontakt ist hat für mich extrem.
Niedrige stufe aber schon nach fünf minuten sagst du naja naja da würde ich dem schon mal so was weiß ich siebzig prozent geben und dann
umso länger es dauert bist du ganz schnell auf hundert prozent also du kannst quasi in diesen parametern selber auch nochmal so eine nicht lineare kurve.
Angeben oder eben eine die anschwellt und auch wieder absteigt je nachdem wie du das einschätzen
und gerade wenn man sich die beispiele anschaut merkt man auch so langsam wie das gemeint ist nur zum beispiel bei diesem bluetooth wo jetzt so viel darüber diskutiert wurde ja kann den bluetooth den abstand so richtig messen und überhaupt und weiß man das überhaupt und spiegelung und reflexion und ja und zuverlässige technologie die nicht dafür gemacht wurde
stimmt alles ja aber in ihrem beispiel sagen sie einfach ja okay du kannst es so einstellen dass jetzt hier die ganz ganz ganz schwachen signale.
Die schneiden wir einfach raus da sagen wir einfach null die wollen wir einfach ignorieren ja bei allen anderen saßen aber hundert prozent.
Das heißt du benutzt das gar nicht sozusagen als als reines.
Als messgerät die jetzt wirklich irgendwas bestimmen soll sondern du machst einfach nur so ein so ein so ein so ein rausschneiden filter wo du sagst ja okay also die ganz schwachen sachen ignorieren wir jetzt mal
weil da können wir uns nicht sicher sein aber alles was irgendwie nennenswert gesehen wurde ist jetzt dabei und bei den,
tageskrise wie gesagt hängt es von dem messergebnis ab und dann die eigentliche gewichtung die man so global machen kann das halt diese sache mit der dauer
welche
dauer ist für uns relevant sagen wir alles was irgendwie fünf minuten lang miteinander zusammen gestanden hat ist schon relevant oder sagen wir erst ab zehn oder fünfzehn oder länger
ist für uns ein wirkliches drama und zusätzlich eben noch über all dem ganzen kommt noch das rein und jetzt gewinnst du also vier,
parameter die dann auf basis der datenlage verglichen werden.
Und dann kannst du diese vier parameter auch nochmal untereinander gewichten also kannst dann sagen okay für uns ist aber der parameter jetzt am allerwichtigsten und der parameter.
Naja den der kann da noch mit reinfließen kannst also sagen diese ganze bluetooth kram interessiert uns nur zu zehn prozent und für uns ist diese
unsere einschätzung wie wir das so sehen viel wichtiger oder die tagesrate geschichte da haben wir sehr genaue daten das.
Soll mal zu fünfzig prozent einfließen und dreißig prozent ist die dauer und der rest verteilt sich so also hier gibt es sehr viel spielraum für die apps und damit natürlich auch sehr viel.
Spielraum für die betreiber einer solchen infrastruktur.
Was man positiv sehen kann was man auch negativ sehen kann weil dadurch dass du dich darum kümmern kannst heißt es auch du musst dich auch drum kümmern muss natürlich dann auch entsprechende größenordnung nehmen und dann kann man natürlich darüber diskutieren ob man nun genug,
und ansatzpunkte hat um hier auch die richtige einschätzung zu machen war das soweit erstmal verständlich.
Ja also
ja ist auf jeden fall ein fortschritt wenn ich mir die schwellenwertes o angucke die dienen natürlich auch zum schutz der privatsphäre welches richtig sehe kann man nicht einfach
ein beliebigen schwellenwert setzen sondern die schwellenwertes sind vorgegeben von apple richtig.
Genau das genauso ist da gibt's ja ganz konkrete bmw m werte die das sind so das sind diese acht gruppen aber wie du dir dann noch bewährtes was anderes.
Aber auch sagen ich kann nur sagen wann kontakte kleiner fünf aber nicht irgendwie kleiner eins und kleiner halbe minute oder kleiner so sondern es gibt noch kleiner fünf ja.
Es gibt kleine fünf minuten fünf minuten zehn fünfzehn zwanzig fünfundzwanzig und alles was länger als dreißig ist das sind die acht festgelegten werte und dann halt diese tagesgruppen noch.
Und auch da gibt es eine gewisse unschärfe sehe ich gerade immer so großer vierzehn und dann immer jeweils für zwei tage zusammen nicht für jeden einzelnen tag
und so mit meinem wir kommen dann rief frage auf okay sind die schwellenwertes jetzt sinnvoll.
Ausgewählt bereits oder müssen da noch nachjustierung kommen da ist ja dann schon irgendwie gut mit den tagen okay keine frage mit den also bei den bei den eurovision risk.
Wenn ich mir halt auch nicht so ganz sicher aber ja wir werden sie schon was dabei gedacht.
Die werden sich sicherlich was dabei gedacht haben erstens lassen sie es ja offen was quasi berücksichtigt wird und.
Das ist es steht der app halt selber extrem frei wie sie diese beurteilung macht ne.
In gewissen grenzen ja kann nur sagen dreißig minuten oder größer dreißig minuten aber ich kann jetzt nicht sagen eine stunde zum beispiel ich hätte gerne.
Also dem beispiel hier für diese transmissionswärmeverlust haben sie ja noch so sachen was weiß ich also es gibt sozusagen ein transmissionswärmeverlust was jetzt direkt
aus der diagnose selber ist also war ist potenziell jemand der sehr infektiös ist ja kann ja sein dass wir dann auch nochmal erkenntnisse haben alter und so weiter was das macht
oder eben berufs daten et cetera all das kann mit reingenommen werden und die apps haben relativ viel freiheit.
Diese exporter zu definieren.
Und dem testergebnis steht halt ja auch dann glaube ich sogar nur eine konzentration
ist mit angegeben so wie hoch die in der probe war die wird glaube ich auch mit ermittelt die kann er natürlich auch mit eingehen in irgendeiner.
Viruslast meinst du jetzt wie viel virus man hatte genau all diese ganzen sachen also da gibt's auf jeden fall eine ganze menge sachen und vorteil ist man kann es machen und der nachteil ist man muss es machen.
Weil irgendwie ist natürlich jetzt die frage woher gewinnen wir denn jetzt überhaupt diese informationen und ein kritikpunkt an diesem dezentralen privatsphäre schonenden modell ist ja auch
naja das heißt in dem moment wo ich jetzt meine parameter anführen und das system sagt ja gab es nicht.
So ein kontakt wie du hier suchst gab es nicht dann erfolgt ja in dem sinne auch erstmal keine rückmeldung.
Du erfährst von diesem test nichts weil du testest bei dir lokal saß einfach so auch so sowas sucht ihr hab ich nicht gehabt.
Lass mich in frieden und dann meldet sich das ding halt auch erstmal wieder nicht zurück und du erhältst jetzt erstmal so unmittelbar also zumindest liest sich
dass ich lese das aus diesem protokoll nicht heraus dass das erstmal nur gewünscht ist oder auch nur irgendwie möglich wäre so eine rückmeldung zu geben.
Weil das würde ja dann im prinzip bedeuten mit gehen wir mal alles was du überprüft hast und schick mir das so darum geht's nicht
will eben diesen ganzen test auf dem telefon durchführen und wenn du halt nicht betroffen bist dann bist du halt nicht betroffen und dann war's das auch aber natürlich ist für eine
gruppe die jetzt versucht hier schlau zu werden aus dem ganzen die information mit ein telefon.
Hat zwar jemanden gesehen aber festgestellt dass das nicht wahr es ist natürlich eine andere information als habe ich nie gesehen und diese unterscheidung kriegt man jetzt erstmal so ohne weiteres nicht
und dann kann man sich natürlich auch fragen wie kann ich denn meine parameter da tun wenn ich darüber keine konkreten erkenntnisse habe.
Ja es gibt natürlich nur sagen zwei probleme die daraus aus der ganzen geschichte entstehen.
Das eine ist gut das hatten wir vorher gab es das auch schon die,
gesundheitsämtern brauchen halt
it-unternehmen dafür also es muss sozusagen in allen gesundheitsämtern müssen neue systeme eingeführt werden oder die systeme die sie haben brauchen neue features so,
weiß nicht was schlimmer ist.
Und von diesen vier parameter gruppen jetzt den sagen bluetooth parameter den internation risk den kannst du in der app.
Setzen also global für für alle der ist für alle fälle gleich so
und dasselbe beim direction risk kann für alle vielleicht gleich eingeschätzt sein kann aber eventuell auch unterschiedlich sein und der david parameter
mission risk parameter gut muss die jetzt nicht nicht aber den david muss man auf jeden fall setzen sonst sonst wird's irgendwie sehr ungenau und beim transmissionswärmeverlust ihn nicht setzt vergibt
man sich glaube ich ein bisschen was das heißt durch diese geschichte müssen jetzt die gesundheitsämtern nicht nur eine tanne vergeben.
Sondern.
Dem jenigen auch diese beiden parameter in irgendeiner form mitteilen und der muss diese dann wiederum der app irgendwie mitteilen.
Ne das ist nicht unbedingt meinst bei der meldung.
Bei der meldung genau.
Das ist ja nicht so weil du mit dem mit dem mit dieser tat sagst du ja nur du darfst deine kies abgeben.
Aber woher ich meine wenn du jetzt wenn ich es richtig sehe.
Dieser days parameter ist das nicht einer der mit,
ausgeschickt wird der sozusagen sich auf den fall bezieht der irgendwo mit dem ausgesendet
daten wenn ich mich infiziert melde ich den rausschicken muss.
Also dem beispiel hier in der app entnehmen würde ich sagen nein sondern das ist eher eine einschätzung des des verhaltens des virus ja man sagt halt einfach.
So und so viel voll wobei es muss ja dann relativ zu der.
Zu zu diesen gesammelten daten sein zu diesem letzten vierzehn tagen also muss es eigentlich schon an dieser diagnose auch mit dranhängen.
Ist das ist eigentlich mein punkt wenn man das wirklich nutzen will variiert das halt von fall zu fall genauso wie der trans mission parameter und.
Sagen die müssen eigentlich mitgeschickt werden so.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht ganz genau können wir jetzt ein bisschen drüber fabulieren mein verständnis war schon so dass wenn man eine meldung hat und man vergibt ihm eine idee.
Diese transaktionsnummer das ist ja etwas was du in deinem backend checkst und damit kannst du dann diese meldung auch mit dem vorliegenden daten verknüpfen deswegen ist meine vorstellung.
Solange ich eines besseren.
Lehrt werde die dass du dann eben diese meldung auch um die von dir gewonnen also vom gesundheitsamt gewonnen informationen anreichert und auf diese art und weise dann zu stellst.
Ja aber dann.
Du meinst dann hat man wieder das privatsphäre problem weil man ja im prinzip das ding tecken könnte mit informationen ja.
Alles ist wirklich ein interessanter punkt dass das werde ich mal das kann ich jetzt nicht beantworten das.
Alles.
Da werde ich mich auf jeden fall nochmal zu schlau machen das ist wirklich ein ganz interessanter punkt überhaupt ist das ja überhaupt der entscheidende punkt also dieses ganze diese abgabe moment das ist und das verteilen es
technisch gesehen pipifax aber diese diese abgabe moment das ist wirklich der der kritische punkt.
Ich habe mir dann auch noch gedanken darüber gemacht wie man denn vielleicht.
Diese ganze erkennung auch noch verbessern könnte oder welche anderen parameter vielleicht in zukunft da noch mit einfluss nehmen können.
Das wird mir hier interessieren weil ich habe da nämlich auch weil du hattest mich ja gefragt irgendwie vor ein paar tagen was man denn da vielleicht noch mitmachen.
Könnte oder was man bräuchte an daten um noch andere dinge interessante dinge dafür zu machen aber erzähl du erstmal ich.
Genau also ich denke dass jetzt erstmal nur so von dieser reihe exporter detects also wenn das telefon gekriegt und sagt so okay wer hat das jetzt wie groß ist das risiko
jetzt hier gewesen in dem moment da wird mir eine
quasi eine anonyme eine person gemeldet die ich vielleicht getroffen habe wie schätze ich jetzt dieses risiko ein jetzt haben wir ja gesehen was die ab jetzt derzeit erstmal hergibt aber es auch.
Klar dass es hier ein moving tage wir befinden uns hier in einem interessanten technischen experiment von dem noch keiner sagen kann ob es überhaupt irgendwas bringt
oder ob's vielleicht erst was bringt wenn man es noch weiter verbessert hat.
Und was natürlich beim telefon eine ganz interessante meter ist natürlich auch so wie wie beweglich war man denn eigentlich.
Also während fünf minuten kontakt habe ich dann die ganze zeit gesessen.
Oder hat mein telefon festgestellt dass ich die ganze zeit gelaufen bin also ist das sozusagen beim joggen ist da jemand neben mir.
Joggt die ganze zeit und wir waren zusammen im wald so oder haben wir fünf minuten oder fünfzehn minuten lang vielleicht im restaurant oder im büro nebeneinander gesessen sowas,
überhaupt gesundheitsdaten in irgendeiner form puls.
Was er nicht alles gerade alles vielleicht ein bisschen weit hergeholt aber grundsätzlich würde ich sagen einfach so so so daten also daten die erstmal so nicht drin sind ne vor allem wenn dieses,
entkoppelt ist und die app darf zwar die location nicht wissen ja aber das betriebssystem kennt ja die location und könnte daraus irgendwelche schlüsse ziehen oder so ja.
Ist jetzt alles so ein bisschen daher gesagt ne aber die andere frage klar was du schon angesprochen hast ist natürlich was könnte man denn sozusagen auch noch
gewinnen wollen aus diesem prozess und ich denke es wäre halt grundsätzlich interessant.
Aus der logik eines gesundheitssystems gedacht was in irgendeiner form diese infektion in griff kriegen wollen man will natürlich auch wissen okay wie viele leute
haben die app installiert das weiß man
ja wie viele leute nehmen jetzt hier wirklich auch daran teil weiß man auch weil man sieht die laden alle irgendwie was runter man sieht die downloadzahlen wie viele telefone sich irgendwie machen was man aber nicht weiß ist wenn halt so ein kiel rausgegangen ist wie viele haben wir jetzt überprüft und haben gesagt.
War nichts
so das ist ja sozusagen die die eigentliche information die das zentrale system sofort rausspucken würde und das ist natürlich etwas schwierig zu gewinnen diese information weil im prinzip
telefone sich ja dann doch wieder zurückmelden müssen um mehr oder weniger anonym sich dazu zu äußern.
Und er hat ja letztes mal schon diese idee mit dieser
differenzial privacy angesprochen das ist ja sozusagen auch so die idee ne wenn man jetzt so eine ganze horde von telefon hat die eben wo dieses system feature angeschaltet ist.
Ohne dass da vielleicht auch eine app installiert ist gewinnen die ja am laufenden meter informationen darüber wie viele all dies sehe ich überhaupt.
Was ja auch erstmal keiner weiß wie verbreitet es denn das eigentlich wie viele wie viele mögliche begegnungen gibt es denn überhaupt wie viele
mögliche events die
schon mal folgenden kriterien in puncto minimum signalstärke und mindestlohn finden überhaupt statt mal ganz unabhängig von irgendeiner konkreten so.
Wobei das können sie gar nicht rauskriegen weil sie das ja nicht dekodieren können das ist interessant diese information gibt's eigentlich gar nicht naja so oder so also
irgendein rauschen so wie gut ist das im betrieb wie viele wie viele werden da gesehen und sowas könnte halt anonym mit dieser differenzial privacy gemessen werden ich weiß nicht ob das getan werden kann ob das überhaupt sinnvoll ist
das das privatsphäre modell greift hier allerdings wirklich ziemlich gut ne und das sind natürlich dann auch alles daten die dann dann in der einschätzung denn sicherheit
auch fehlen.
Mir waren halt zwei dinge eingefallen die man eigentlich jetzt erstmal aus der aus der zielstellung also was.
Würde man gerne mit so 'ner app.
Erreichen oder besser hinkriegen als man es bisher hinkriegt und da ist natürlich das ganze thema geschwindigkeit und da hatten wir.
Die frage ob man.
Eventuell vorsieht dann 'ne möglichkeit dass wenn ich eine warnung bekomme.
Dass ich dann quasi selber sowas wie eine warnung losschicken kann an meine kontakte leute ich habe hier eine warnung bekommen,
so keine ahnung
ist vielleicht nichts so aber auf jeden fall ich habe hier eine warnung bekommen und fühlt euch mal sagen als warnung zweiten grades was ja in der realität denn auch.
Oft so mündlich passiert dass natürlich sich das rumspricht also wenn jemand ich.
Aus der familie so auf der arbeit hab war ich mit jemandem zusammen der halt infiziert
war sagten familienmitglied und dann weißt du halt ahja okay so familienmitglied könnte irgendwie sich angesteckt haben und ist jetzt auch erst mal in.
Selbst quarantäne bis halt rauskommt so wie das ist das ist halt der punkt bei einer generationstag mit von vier tagen.
So und wo die symptome sich erst im schnitt am fünften tag entwickeln hat derjenige wenn er sich denn angesteckt hat wahrscheinlich schon bereits weitere leute angesteckt.
Typischerweise ich meine wenn ihr am tag fünf krank wird
und schon bisher getestet wird so tag sechs sieben acht wie auch immer
noch mehr zeit vergehen so und in der zeit kann halt der virus schon wieder irgendwie mehrere hops gemacht haben das heißt du willst eigentlich wenn du schon mit einer gewissen zeit verzögerung
startest mit diesem handicap von sechs sieben acht tagen wirst du halt eigentlich
diese sechs sieben acht tage quasi aufholen das heißt du willst eigentlich mindestens sankt zwei potentielle generation waren und es könnten
wäre theoretisch technisch zumindest könnte die die app das das tun.
Ich habe da gerade mal in die dokumentation nochmal reingeschaut wo wir das jetzt nämlich gesagt hat weil das ist ein punkt den hatte ich mir jetzt gar nicht so.
Der hat sich nur so nebenbei notiert weil ich das in dem moment nicht verstanden habe ich habe jetzt gerade nochmal parallel draufgeschaut und für mich ist es immer noch etwas unklar ich sitze hier mal versuche mal hier so aus der übersetzen aus diesem
dokument zu zitieren also hier gibt es ein diagramm wo einerseits erklärt wird wie diese risk levels diese exporte level mit diesem diagnose
im rahmen eines sogenannten sharing schemas weitergereicht werden also es ist sozusagen,
prinzip vorgesehen so so diese einschätzung mit der meldung in dem fall wahrscheinlich von dem telefon ausgehend weiterzuleiten.
Und jetzt wird es für mich ein bisschen schwierig weil hier steht auf diesem wege kann ein secondary export,
user also es gibt hier wieder klassische klassiker bob und alice also bob ist.
Verifiziert der positiver alice ist sozusagen primär primary expost also sozusagen erstkontakt.
Und dann heißt es nämlich hier auf diese art und weise indem man diesen level durch reicht kann man.
Optional sofort von dieser app notifiziert werden obwohl hier kein test vorliegt.
Und der grund warum ich das so verwirrt hat ist dass sie so in dieser doku halt explizit sagen ja wenn ihr diagnose kies veröffentlicht werden dann muss da explizit nochmal eine bestätigung,
erfolgen und in diesem fall würde ja sozusagen der kiefer öffentlich werden ohne dass man das
bestätigt oder vielleicht muss man es auch bestätigen aber es standen nur was von diagnose drin also das habe ich noch nicht so ganz verstanden dass es uns weiter bereich der ein bisschen unklar ist aber ich habe den eindruck
dass so etwas vorgesehen ist ich weiß bloß nicht wie automatisch das ist.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus dass es auf jeden fall auch dann in dem fall sagen was hoch poppt und ich fragte hier so willst du irgendwie.
Deine zweite kontakte auch mit benachrichtigen wenn sie so eine funktion
einbauen also ich würde das auf jeden fall für sinnvoll halten wenn's die möglichkeit gäbe und ich würde so eine funktion auch definitiv selber nutzen.
Also da scheint noch eine menge musik drin zu sein und man muss mal schauen wie sich das nochmal so entfaltet.
Eine kleine.
Anmerkungen noch die mich ein bisschen verwirrt und zwar haben apple und google angekündigt dass sie im laufe des mai das halt jetzt veröffentlicht werden ich rechne jetzt so mit mitte mai.
Das ist so das was ich so gehört habe ist ja alles beta
test und werden sicherlich noch ein paar bugfixes haben und dieses und jenes aber ich würde mal meinen so in der woche vielleicht wenn wir hier nächste woche uns wieder drüber unterhalten kann es sein dass das rad ist schon draußen ist vielleicht dauert's noch ein paar tage länger aber ich würde sagen so in den nächsten zwei wochen
werden wir das sehen jetzt haben sie angekündigt dass sie later apple das immer so schön formuliert ja,
später im jahr planen sie das auch noch in ihr system einzubauen,
und da habe ich das kam auch schon am anfang und ich mich die ganze zeit am kopf gekratzt was zur hölle meinen sie denn damit weil.
Sie bauen es ja jetzt schon in diesem system ein es ist im betriebssystem dieser api ist.
Ausgeliefert und dann kann man die app installieren und dann ist es da aber sie kündigen an.
Dass sie später gedenken dass ins system zu integrieren.
Ich hätte eine idee was sie damit meinen könnten.
Ja bitte jetzt darf vermutet werden ich habe da auch so ein paar aber auch echt nur vermutung weil eigentlich ist ja schon alles da was ist dann noch da was jetzt noch nicht da ist.
Meine vermutung wäre.
Das damit gemeint ist dass die app zusammen mit dem system gewandelt wird das heißt dass du die app gar nicht installieren musst sondern dass die app vor installiert ist.
Das wäre sozusagen eine bedeutung von ins system einbauen.
Ist mir zwar noch nicht ganz klar wie sie das machen wollen so aber das wäre dann natürlich dann hältst du die app schon mal einfach gleich auf jedem telefon und müsst sie nicht erst im appstore suchen.
Ja aber das jetzt irgendwie die app von deutschland mit einem neu installierten telefon daherkommt.
Warum müssen sie da ich meine sowas müssen sie nicht ins system einbauen ja also sie sie könnten sie könnten auch sagen okay hier ist die app alle sollten die jetzt haben wir pushen die man überall rein
du machst einfach so ein auto download dazu muss es aber nicht ins system einbauen das ist ein anderer vorgang.
Also dann hätten sie gesagt wir werden dafür sorgen dass diese app überall installiert ist punkt.
Vielleicht bauen sie einen.
Downloaden ein der es dir ermöglicht irgendwie auszuwählen auf irgendeine art und weise welche landeseben du denn jetzt zum drecken.
Ja aber das können sie jetzt auch schon ihrem app store machen ich meine du gehst auf app store und dann sagen sie hallo guten tag die app tipp of the week.
Ja ja nee nee nee das ist das ist schon noch was anderes weil wenn du sagen nur eine app.
Sagen die app darauf haben willst kannst du das nicht anhand der spracheinstellungen machen oder klar.
Du kannst es anhand des appstores machen aber es kann halt aber ich weiß auch nicht ob das gut ist dass wenn du ja verstehst was ich meine.
Ja aber ich glaube das ist das geringste problem.
Also ich ich glaube ich glaube nicht dass das so etwas irgendeine ankündigung schon von tag eins an.
In dieser protokoll spitze verdient hätte das ist das ist eine reine app verteilung geschichte die sie irgendwann mal releasen können oder so.
Was glaubst du denn was das.
Ich weiß es nicht ja ich ich weiß es nicht ich ich rätsel aber ich habe halt drüber nachgedacht was was kann denn das bedeutet wenn apple sagt sie bauen etwas ins system ein das heißt ja dass sie eine funktionalität in ihrem system haben.
Die jetzt noch nicht im system ist und das könnte natürlich bedeuten einerseits dass diese app in irgendeiner form oder die funktionalität die diese app.
Hat im system ist.
Dass sie sozusagen ihre eigene app hat weil letzten endes schon am anfang erwähnt die app selber macht nicht sehr viel die hängt vor allem von daten von draußen ab.
Das heißt wichtig in dieser ganzen entwicklung ist gar nicht so sehr die app wichtig ist das backend was diese information mit der diese app arbeitet zuführt.
Das ist aber ein relativ großer aufwand da müssen jetzt irgendwie.
Leute darüber nachdenken da müssen gesundheitsämtern mit reingebracht werden etcetera man sieht was das jetzt alles ausgelöst hat da wird sap gerade richtig glühen und schrauben und mit tausend leuten reden und pipapo.
Was ist jetzt wenn du länder hast die diesen aufwand nicht leisten können was ist mit.
Gana was ist mit tansania was ist mit südafrika was ist mit.
Allen anderen ländern die nicht industrielle super staaten sind die immer eben so ein software großkonzern aus dem schrank holen und sagen können
jetzt hier mal dreißig über bezahlte programmierer machen mal die nächsten drei monate nichts anderes als das was ist mit denen die haben auch vor allem noch ein viel größeres problem.
Und das jetzt alles vermutung ja alles vermutung aber ich kann mir das auch gut vorstellen warum sollte apple nicht sagen okay ihr habt hier so eine infrastruktur nicht,
euch programmiert das jetzt hier auch keiner und ihr habt auch in dem sinne gar kein gesundheitssystem wo man sich groß andocken können aber wir wollen trotzdem ermöglichen dass diese benachrichtigung,
erfolgen kann dass wenn jemand positiv getestet ist schnell sagen kann hier warnung,
und das ganze bedarf ja minimal eigentlich nur ein nur in anführungsstrichen eines andocken von solchen testinstanz.
Sagen wir mal du hast jetzt in unserem afrikanischen land so eine
mission vom von der who oder was nicht oder wie auch immer in dem moment zuständig wäre die solche testlabor betreiben.
Und die registrieren sich jetzt bei google und apple und sagen hier hallo wir sind offiziell international tätig hilfsmittel wir führen tests durch.
Dann kommt da leute zu denen hin die machen tests.
Telefone sind in afrika sehr verbreitet im übrigen ja also das ist da sozusagen sing marthonlesung gibt's auch in billig die ganze afrikanische wirtschaft basiert auf smartphones
oder überhaupt erstmal auf mobiltelefon aber zunehmenden maße natürlich auch auf smartphones
und vielleicht ist es der sudan nicht das beste beispiel aber südafrika nigeria etcetera andere länder die von sowas profitieren können wenn du also sozusagen nur dieses,
ich habe einen test gemacht
und er ist bestätigt und du hast eine eine entsprechende registrierung von einer solchen test institution oder gruppe oder so und die registriert sich dann bei apple dann könnte apple oder google halt ne
die sind dann sozusagen registriert die dürfen so ein code ausgeben.
Und damit ist die meldung draußen weil ansonsten muss dieses backend erstmal nicht so sehr viel mehr machen als das an die telefone weiterleiten damit die testen können das ist im prinzip erstmal alles ne
was halt noch mit dazu kommt ist diese ganze gewichtung über die wir jetzt gesprochen haben dieses risk ist dass man etcetera later.
Wissen wir aber wahrscheinlich wie diese parameter auszusehen haben und können die mehr oder weniger global anwenden oder auch entsprechend nachführen durch weitere erkenntnisse es wäre also durchaus vorstellbar ich weiß nicht ob es kommen wird aber
ich lese raus es wäre durchaus vorstellbar dass sie auch diese download infrastruktur machen weltweit,
dass es nur ein anführungsstrichen nur noch erforderlich ist solche test institutionen zu registrieren und dann läuft dieser ganze hase ganz unabhängig von irgendeinem gesundheitssystem und warnt die leute entsprechend.
Das wäre natürlich auch eine variante dass sie sozusagen die app für den rest der welt machen.
Und damit halt irgendwie auch auch für alle weil,
klar möchtest du es ganz gerne mit den gesundheitsämtern irgendwie zusammenbringen aber das.
Ist nicht das hauptproblem das hauptproblem ist erstmal leute waren,
und leute dazu bringen dass sie sich in sicherheit bringen damit andere leute in sicherheit sind und diese dienstleistung können sie mit diesem privacy modell durchführen weil sie müssen halt nichts wissen.
Alles was sie wissen müssen ist wer sind die gruppen die sagen dürfen das war ein positiver test das ist
alles was dieses system braucht
und wenn du dafür ein registrierungsset system hast wenn sie dafür eine internationale organisation aufbauen die das halt macht zum beispiel mit der uno mit der who zusammen dass sie sagen hier,
weiß hat kontakt zu den einzelnen ländern weiß wer da irgendwie zuständig ist registriert die labore registriert mobile testlabor die die unterwegs sind oder eben auch gesundheitsämtern alle können sich da einklinken und können sofort diese infrastruktur
benutzen und jedes telefon was im umlauf ist misst einfach mit und verteilt diese warnung also ich könnte mir das ganz gut vorstellen das ist etwas was sie sich durch
dieses prinzip privacy bei design verkaufen sie können das ganze system hochskalieren auf die ganze welt im prinzip.
Ohne irgendeiner form informationen darüber zu gewinnen wer mit wem wann wo es etcetera p und das wahrscheinlich auch der grund warum sie da auch so krass drauf drängen.
Dass das so ist dass das nicht.
Angedacht wird als ein system wir wissen viel über euch weil wenn du erstmal über irgendjemand irgendwas weißt bricht das ganze konzept halt wie ein kartenhaus zusammen wenn du es eben versuchst auf die ganze welt hochzuskalieren.
Ja wir werden sehen ich bin sehr gespannt wie das mit der verbreitung also wie schnell sich die app tatsächlich verbreiten wird wie viele sie nutzen werden bei apple
sehe ich eine sehr sehr hohe quote einfach weil dort auch die meisten leute des aktuelle betriebssystem fahren einfach
relativ schnell also es geht irgendwie das sind ein paar wochen dann fast hat der großteil hat aktualisiert und
hat die funktionalität zur verfügung als auch die frage wie viele davon das machen werden aber ich.
Denke eher eine eine hohe quote aber.
Was machen werden zu aktualisieren.
Die die app die app dann auch sozusagen aktiv betreiben so und.
Das ding fängt sofort an zu funken in dem moment wo es aktualisiert ist die app kann man dann immer später noch auf zuruf installieren und das.
Kann sich auf eine ganz interessante weise dann noch verstärken wenn sowas überhaupt erstmal passiert wenn die ersten berichte kommen von leute wurden notifiziert kriegt das auf einmal eine ganz andere dynamik.
Aber ich sage die frage ist sagen erstmal tatsächlich also wie viele leute sagen erstmal werden sie technisch dazu in der lage oder wären das nach.
Bisherigen erfahrungen tun und
ich hatte mal ja von ich betreibe ja ein messaging dienst auch noch wo ich dann sehen kann welche betriebssysteme die leute so fahren
das ist zwar jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht repräsentativ für irgendwie alle leute aber habe ich mal einen auszug
von getwittert von paar wochen so android und zusammen jeweils wie viel prozent welche betriebssystems version da gerade fahren,
und ich meine da ist da ist so dass es etwa also in meiner stadt etwa doppelt so viele android user gibt die die app nutzen wie user.
Ich weiß nicht ob das entsprechend auch der allgemeinen verteilung von wahrscheinlich gibt es ein bisschen weniger eiweiß ist wahrscheinlich überrepräsentiert aber vielleicht sind auch leute da app affiner also
eins zu zwei ist auf jeden fall eine positive zahl so das heißt dann haben wir aber jetzt.
Sagen innerhalb von einem monat sagen wir mal die hälfte der apple-nutzer,
das wären dann die hälfte also ein sechstel der mobiltelefon nutzer die.
Übrigens glaube ich liegt fast ich glaube bei achtundachtzig prozent oder so der deutschen haben smartphones also ziemlich hoch geht an die an die neunzig prozent.
Ran und auf android ist dann natürlich die frage gut da gibt's ein paar große.
Und die müssen natürlich mit betriebssystem-update nachziehen und dann ist die frage.
Wie weit zurück es denn geht weil doch ein sehr großer teil der deutsch-lutherischen ich hab's jetzt nicht genau im,
im blick aber ich würde mal sagen größenordnungsmäßigen die hälfte wahrscheinlich wird es gar kein update geben für deren geräte mindestens die hälfte.
Naja ich weiß es auch nicht genau aber ich bin ja nicht ganz so skeptisch weil es ist dann natürlich so google wird das über diese play services aus
liefern du brauchst keinen betriebssystem-update dafür was ist mehr library update und damit können sie halt theoretisch sogar bis zu sechs zurück beliefern von daher hat google im prinzip denselben
in die ganze insta wie apple auch vergleichsweise.
Telefone die dieses bluetooth vier zwei was glaube ich erforderlich ist oder ideal ist können gibt es seit.
Mindestens fünf sechs jahren.
Ja also wer zweitausendzwölf glaube ich so sind die ersten irgendwie.
Bluetooth vier das ist so alphorn vier s und so weiter und,
vier zwei hat so dann irgendwie so seit dem iphone sechs so und iphone sechs das ist das was jetzt überall rausfällt also im prinzip die base
bei apple kann es komplett und das sieht bei android jetzt auch nicht so sehr viel anders aus also meine man kann andere menge vorwerfen aber gerade was so hardware features betrifft sind diese telefon ja dann doch immer auch.
Das ist immer so das womit groß angegeben wird so hat auch schon hier neueste version von und ich glaube dass,
letztlich nur eine frage wie wie weit sie bereit oder in der lage sind ihre software nach hinten
anzupassen um dieses feature zu unterstützen bei apple rechne ich mindestens mit einem release für das aktuelle betriebssystem und das davor und wenn sie das davor auch noch machen.
Dann dürfte die abdeckung auch eher so im bereich von fünfundneunzig prozent liegen.
Und der ganze pool verjüngt sich ja am laufenden meter also das wird sozusagen auch die ganze zeit immer nur immer besser.
Ich halte viel mehr als die hälfte
nicht für realistisch ich glaube wenn es aber selbst wenn's ein viertel wären also weiß ich nicht bei zwanzig millionen wären wäre es schon glaube ich ganz ganz cool um irgendwie auf dreißig oder vierzig millionen
komm
kommt man könnte man glaube ich schon ein bisschen was damit reißen wobei wir auch immer wieder festgestellt haben also retten wird uns die app
nicht so dann wie du es auch so richtig sagt dass sie kann halt letztlich die arbeit der gesundheitsämtern
dahingehend unterstützen dass sich die leute halt vielleicht schneller für einen test melden einfach weil wir werden nämlich auch jetzt langsam das problem haben die halt immer jetzt.
Fand das so lustig so mit der debatte um die erhöhung der test kapazitäten weil irgendwann festgestellt bevor das dann plötzlich in der presse hoch poppte
dass die test kapazitäten von über achthunderttausend die woche haben aber nur dreihundertfünfzigtausend tests gemacht werden pro woche
im moment oder dachte ich moment alle reden irgendwie von test test test und da laufen wir natürlich jetzt wenn die zahlen immer kleiner werden
ja wird es einfach gar nicht genug leute geben die sich testen lassen ich fand das sowieso schon so interessant wo denn überhaupt bisher so viele leute herkommen nämlich zwanzig mal so viele
wie jetzt mit corvette infiziert sind lassen sich ja testen das heißt es müssen halt ohne ende irgendwie andere atemwegs
erkrankungen unterwegs sein also zwanzig mal so viele jedenfalls wie wie
und da hatte ich mich halt auch so so ein bisschen gewundert jedenfalls laufen wenn das problem dass man sagen uns vielleicht testbild lege
ausgehen möglicherweise oder testkandidaten und so eine app ist dann natürlich
ein ganz guter mechanismus um ganz gezielt zu testen und vor dem hintergrund könnte man vielleicht auch empfehlen ruhig ein bisschen breiter zu
warnen und dann ein bisschen breiter zu testen als das vielleicht jetzt unbedingt.
Notwendig wäre oder man das in der vergangenheit gemacht hat weil wir haben die test kapazitäten und sinnvoller als ja die waren in der nähe also warum nicht testen.
Es wird auch davon abhängen wie die kosten übernommen werden weil einer der gründe warum die test kapazitäten derzeit nicht genutzt werden ist dass sie halt bezahlt werden müssen sind alles private labore.
Diese dienstleistung durchführen weiß jetzt nicht so ganz genau was und test kostet um höherer zweistelliger eurobetrag auf jeden fall und wenn du jetzt jetzt beschließt mit
hier alle unsere mitarbeiter ja könnte ja jeder konzern könnte ja jetzt im prinzip ankommen und sagen bei uns wird jetzt einmal die woche die komplette etage durchgetestet.
Bei siemens oder so.
Klar könnte man machen aber hast du halt dann so und so viel tausend mitarbeiter jede woche mal was weiß ich fünfundsiebzig euro kostet halt geld muss bezahlt werden muss irgendwie jemand bereit sein auch für dich die kohle auf den tisch zu legen.
Mal ganz abgesehen davon dass es auch noch kostenaufwandsaspekten zu führen und so weiter und.
Das ist so ein ding und insofern stimme ich dir da auch total zu muss natürlich auch bedeuten dass die ansprache dieser app entsprechend ist nicht,
alle gehen ja immer davon aus mit alarm alarm alarm ja so quarantäne sofort oder so ich glaube gar nicht mal dass das das ist was wir so primär sehen werden sondern es wird.
Kann sehr gut sein dass wir da ein sehr nur viertes so so ein wetterbericht ja so was mal wieder so in der nähe von infizierten anzug
du wärst mal so ein kandidat für den test und
hier ist übrigens eine map mit deinen nächsten test stellen und hier ist ein code womit du da sofort auch vorgelassen wirst weil du hast hier
begründete verdacht und keine angst der code ist jetzt nicht.
Personifiziert ne sondern es halt nur so ein code und.
Dann kannst du da einfach hinmarschieren und übrigens deine krankenkasse das ist halt auch automatisch vom kranken von der krankenkasse gedeckt ist wahrscheinlich eh so aber.
So in dieser richtung ist dass die leute einfach wissen kostet nix hast ein anlass muss auch nicht warten muss er nicht fünf stunden lang
in so einer durch durch solche zone mit anderen husten rumstehen sondern das geht hier irgendwie ordentlich oder dein hausarzt kann es machen oder was auch immer und darüber kann man es ganz gut in den griff kriegen.
Genau ne also ja.
Ich will die kommission auch langsam zu ende bringen oder hast natürlich total recht ne auch ein teil dieser diskussion um diese app ist ja auch interessanterweise kommt es aus dieser linse nerd ecke ne also hier so brust schneider und so weiter krypto,
raten die sich dann dazu geäußert haben die auch sagen muss so wo liegt eure kompetenz also ja das könnte ja
positives geben und so für so ein kryptographie und unsere netz
werk computer menschen ist so voll positiv vor sehr dass es so alarm alarm dinge laufen nicht so wie sie sein sollen ja meine nähere welt bricht zusammen wobei hier kann es halt sein so
ja okay du verdächtigt jemanden vielleicht infiziert zu sein und im schlimmsten fall hast du dir halt dann getestet und dann weißt du es dann halt auch ne so.
Vor allen dingen vor allen dingen vor dem hintergrund das war immer wieder betonen dass ja im moment nur um die fünf prozent der tests positiv sind das heißt wir haben ja sozusagen in der momentanen situation
schon sagen fünfundneunzig prozent.
Falsche vermutung ne.
Verdächtige die sich als unschuldig erweisen beziehungsweise als unschädlich muss.
Genau das könnt ihr natürlich dann echt interessant sein zu sehen wie die quote bei den leuten ist die von ihrer app gewarnt werden,
haben wir da einen höheren turnover und das das kann man dann auch messen ohne irgendeine privatsphäre groß zu verletzen die leute kommen da hin und sagen ja hier ich bin ab induziert ja das wird dann als häkchen einfach vermerkt.
Kann er ja belegen und dann kriegst du am schluss halt wirklich raus so waren wir mal jetzt werden alles super läuft fünfundvierzig aus der nase gezogen hat fünfundvierzig prozent aller leute die,
basis einer app warnung getestet worden hatten auch tatsächlich virus und das ist eine grandiose zahl ja klar also dann bei den hälften falsch gewarnt
aber gut der free to go und sind nicht infiziert ne so hoch wird's nicht sein ja aber das ist zehn oder fünfzehn prozent sein.
Sagen wir so wenn's wenn's genauso viel oder wenn's nicht signifikant weniger wären als der durchschnitt was wir jetzt haben wir selbst wenn's nur die hälfte von dem wäre so
wäre super wenn wir überhaupt pose positive sagt wenn wir überhaupt einen positiven finden aber ich sage mal wenn wir,
dadurch durch durch leute die gewarnt werden wenn wir dadurch einfach,
mehr und sei es fünf prozent mehr sei es zehn prozent mehr an infizierten finden dann ist das ein echter gewinn.
Und das kann das auch signifikant senken.
Also wir werden sehen wir werden sehen.
Wir werden sehen es bleibt spannend pavel ich denke wir müssen's mal abschließend für heute das war wieder alles sehr unterhaltsam aber auch lang.
Vielen dank
und natürlich auch vielen dank fürs zuhören hier bei u k w vielleicht ein kurzer satz noch
hier zu meiner
produktion bin gerade total im corona modus ist eigentlich auch total super findet eine menge statt wenn euch das gefällt dann könnt ihr mal falls ihr das ohnehin nicht tut auch
erwägen die metaebene finanziell zu unterstützen link ist in den schoß metaebene im spenden was ich gerne sehe sind.
Daueraufträge kleine spenden will in der lage ist fünfzig cent im monat zu geben das hilft schon eine menge
alle die das schon tun vielen dank alle die es vor allem in diesen zeiten nicht eingestellt haben auch besonders vielen dank das hilft auf jeden fall
weiter und so wird es auch weiterhin hier noch interessantes material geben wir bleiben auf jeden fall dran paul und ich denke wir schauen mal ob die welt nächste woche noch steht richtig.
Also ich glaube nächste woche wahrscheinlich auch noch die woche drauf denke ich wird das thema noch interessant.
Das sind die prognosen auf die alle gewartet haben.
Welt steht noch in zwei wochen super dann sagen wir tschüs.